Hello!
Yeah, Mexico!
You're welcome, Mexico.
I like to think that I helped out.
I did my part.
I mean, I feel like this music isn't very, uh, isn't very,
you know, I don't know, football-y.
right now let me see if i can find a copyright free i don't
want to get dmc'd by uh fifa as well copyright free fifa
music gracias toky oh no problem no problem in spanish i am
uh how do i say it
You're welcome.
No problem.
No, no problem.
Donata, donata.
See you guys, I am honorary Mexican.
Let's see.
Viva Mexico!
At least somebody's winning today!
Alright, let's watch the games.
We could watch the games.
How do I watch the games?
Mexico versus... Who are they fighting today?
Mexico versus... I know Korea was fighting... I think South
Africa?
Was it South Africa or is it Mexico versus... Oh, Czech
Republic.
Yeah, I know Korea.
Who won?
Who won between Korea versus South Africa?
It's on TSN.
Korea won?
Okay.
We're still going to fight Korea, though.
We're to watch.
If only I have a TV.
right now i don't want to watch the text live okay the cps
has a live stream guys i don't have a tv oh there it is is
this live i assume oh there it is i think i'm watching this
illegally where's the legal one is there a legal version of
this i don't want to i clicked on it and i have a feeling
that this is not the legal version of it.
I know, that's why I'm trying to find the legal version.
I'm trying.
It literally showed up on Google.
It showed up on Google.
And I thought that was the legal version.
I clicked it and I was like, that does not look legal.
Oh, wait.
I have Disney Plus.
Does it have it on Disney Plus?
Oh, my God.
The sub to Crave again.
God, fucking Crave.
Oh, my God.
I unsubbed to Crave.
I guess I have the So back to grave.
It's just going to start searching the exact phrase.
You're the first result on Google.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah, another goal!
Yeah!
Is it true?
Another goal?
Do we get another one?
Let's go.
Wow, I turned on stream and we start.
scoring what are the odds of that oh I'm not gonna say that
I'm not saying that you know it was all me but I don't know
no problem denada denada my fellow Mexicans denada
A cool spot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mexico scores again.
All right.
Let's, all right.
Let's, we are watching Mexico versus, uh, check.
I just say that.
I'll do that right now.
All right.
I found a, I, I found a, I found a stream I can watch.
I think this, I, I found one.
All right.
Don't keep giving us a Canadian buck.
Take one.
Man, Ramos.
It's because it's because I was thinking of the super chat.
I'm like, thank you.
Thank you.
It's because of that one Mexican lady that was like, are you
Mexican?
Like it was literally, I was at a restaurant and I saw
everybody drinking this like shot.
I was so confused.
I was like, well, everyone, like everyone's drinking.
I want one.
And then I asked the server and she was like, it's not for
you.
Like we don't sell this.
And I was like, what?
What?
The server was like, we're not selling that.
It's not for you.
And I was so confused.
I was like, everyone around me has it.
Like, I don't know, it was green.
I was green with a Canadian flag on it.
So I was so confused, because I was just like, how come I'm
the only one that can't purchase this drink?
And then I realized, I, and then, and then I realized, like,
you know, they're all like, Mexico, salute.
they're like in spanish they're mexico salute and i was like
oh i'm the only non-mexican person in here like so so i was
just like oh i just happened to went to a restaurant where
all the mexicans were there for for the world cup because i
i knew mexico mexico was playing like after like you know it
was the last game um so i was so i was so confused and then
The lady next to me was like are you Mexican and I was like,
no, I'm not I came here to watch the Canada versus
Switzerland game And I'm just getting food and she's like
don't worry.
You're an honorary Mexican today.
I was like, oh, thank you.
Yay You know I was just like I was just like oh, yay Wait,
it's oh wait, is it both games going on?
Let's let's let's it's time to dual watch.
Okay, so I've thought I didn't realize they're both going on
the same time.
Yeah, I got the Mexico pass right now I do Have the Mexico I
have the Mexican pass.
I'm an honoring Mexican All right guys we can do a watch.
I know it's gonna give you a recap, but we'll do it.
Oh, then we'll well I mean Uh, oh, did she talk about what
did she say Tom they give a super chat?
Thank you.
Can I?
the austria watch a lot what does she talk about all right
we'll do a watch it's okay i have this is what two monitors
are for guys the power of two monitors i don't know if if
it's south africa won against korea wouldn't we have a
better chance against korea because korea is worse than
South Africa?
If, like, South Africa scored against Korea, then wouldn't
that mean South Africa is better than Korea?
Or is it Korea?
I don't know.
Because isn't that how it goes?
No?
Is South Africa worse than Korea?
What's the power scaling?
What's the power ranking?
I don't know the power ranking.
I just knew I was looking at placements.
I was looking at like fifa placements and it's not okay it's
really funny for canada it was like 80th place like for fifa
placement it was like 80th 90th 100 120th uh 70th placement
60 40 and it started slowly going down in recent years it's
only yeah what's the football meta what i was just like i
was like we have, by the way, for those who don't know
Canada's record, we have not qualified for FIFA for 80% of
FIFA's lifespan.
That's how we have not qualified for 80% of the time FIFA
has been around.
So it's like, so I'm like, I don't know.
I just know Canada is not the best at, at football.
That's all I know.
I know South Korea is really, really good at, soccer slash
football I know that so I don't know about South Africa um I
didn't know about South Africa so I'm just like wait if
South Africa scored wouldn't that mean South Africa is
better than Korea um if they're winning the Korea versus
South Africa game because that's like the tier list you know
or is it like the situation where that it's like rock paper
scissors yeah so I don't know which team is better i don't
like korea has had um has has been qual has qualified for
fifa numerous times um so i have no idea kanda's a little
yeah kanda's a little brother of kaka but in recent years
they have a good squad yeah think of the super chat cool
spot thank you thank you um so yeah no for those who didn't
know i was physically at the kanda versus switzerland game
um And it was really fun.
For my very first time, I've never experienced World Cup
before.
And I think the last time I've watched World Cup was the
South Africa.
When World Cup was in South Africa because of the Mouva
Zellas.
I think that has been the most.
I think that has been the most hype World Cup has ever been
since then.
So it was like, you know, that's when the last time I've
watched it on, like, you know, on tv and everything so yeah
you see the my photo in the background that's i took that
photo like i was like i literally took that photo so um so
this is my photo by the way you can't copyright me because i
took that photo uh it's it's my photo i didn't take it off i
didn't steal it from anybody um so yeah i was i was
literally physically there um i got a really nice seat i was
like no matter what happens even we lose which unfortunately
that's what happened i was just like even if we lose at
least you know at least it's like it was very comfortable I
was like, oh, at least it'll be, like, super comfortable.
You know, that was, that was, like, my way of thinking it.
Okay, wait, actually, I think I might have to, I'm going to
subscribe to Crave.
All right, let me get back in Crave.
All right, Crave, I'm back, Crave.
I'm back.
I realized, I realized.
uh activate wait where is it okay that is my do i have okay
i do i realize i thought it was an official stream but i
realized it was a video game simulation oh oh shit wait yeah
i realized i realized i was watching a video game simulation
because it looked so real it looked so real and then it
zoomed in and i was like that's not real i was just like
wait a minute that's not a real that that looks like a video
game that looks like a fucking video game all right let me
okay world cup world cup uh includes all 24 7 ts okay i'm
not getting ads standard with no ads please i'm not i'm not
paying for ads right now all right no we're just gonna grab
oh yeah no i zoomed in it zoomed into the face and i was
like that's that's that's not a human face like yeah all
right give me a second and grab my wallet i'll be right back
I'm back I got I had to get my card for this um I had to
grab my wallet because all I could bring was my fucking
wallet because they had a really strict clear bag policy and
I had no clear bags because I was just like I'm gonna bring
my wallet just gonna hold my chunky ass wallet while I'm
going inside um let's see which is crazy because what I
thought was really funny was they had a no bag policy but
like um When you're in there, when you buy stuff, they give
you a not clear bag.
So, like, I was so confused because I was just like, I guess
it's because when you're going in, they think you won't
bring anything.
But then, like, when you're leaving, like, you know, they're
like, oh, you're not going to do anything crazy.
Like, I don't know.
You're not going to fucking steal any.
You're not going to steal the FIFA trophy.
By the way, I took a photo of the trophy.
So, yeah, so I was just like, I guess, like, I can't steal
anything when I'm, like, in there.
So that's why they're like, it's fine.
It's fucking fine.
All right.
Upcoming.
Where the fuck?
I literally subscribed.
Um, where's my live FIFA?
Um, excuse me.
Where is it?
Uh, upcoming FIFA, Switzerland.
I don't want to.
Where's my?
Where is it?
I subscribed.
Excuse me.
I gave you $80.
It's like, I gave you $80.
How do I navigate this?
Ways to watch.
I literally subscribed.
You can't do this to me.
Oh my god.
I have 20 more minutes.
I literally subscribed to all 104 matches.
It says all 104.
Where is TSN?
Where the fuck is TSN?
I don't know how to navigate Crave.
I'm gonna get craved for this.
Okay, live 2D.
Okay, like not live 2D.
Live.
Skip.
I don't need to personalize my experience.
Live TV.
Sorry, I meant live TV, not live 2D.
All right, where is it?
Better sleep.
E-talk?
Where the fuck is World Cup?
Where is World Cup?
use okay here you go view details um senegal versus no we're
we're in i don't know this okay i fucking hate crave i this
is actually absolutely terrible to navigate like there's
every game except for the game that's playing right now
there's they don't have the live games what's the point i'm
watching a i'm watching a fucking video game simulation
right now i'm oh my god i'm watching a video game simulation
they have bots of like all the other games but they don't
have like the live okay upcoming there's ctv group l panama
versus england colombia versus where is south Korea versus
versus South Africa and also Mexico versus Czech.
Okay, watch Shana.
Oh, I'm the big why is it giving me the big band theory, the
bus pass utilization?
Excuse me.
Where is it?
Okay.
Guys, we don't have Fox.
I don't think we have Fox 1.
is Canada we're talking about.
This is Canada we're talking about right now.
I don't think I have FIFA.
I don't think I have Fox one.
I dropped $80 because they said, they said FIFA was on,
we're to watch, we're to watch FIFA live, um, live stream on
online okay except uh I I please I just please
TSN has it okay TSN watch it live okay TSN live there we go
oh my god I got it subscribe now I am not subscribed I have
Crave!
Did I not buy Crave, guys?
Come on.
It says 44 live FIFA World Cup matches including Team...
Oh, the one time it does not include Team Canada.
There's no way.
way there's no fucking way the one time it just only had
team cat guys i think it just only had team canada day games
i'm pretty sure they only had like they choose the matches
they want to broadcast oh my god all right all right tsn
plan okay so i do have wait i do have yes continue with this
continue with my oh my god wait wait fifa world cup i'm on
tsn right now live
am i what oh my god got it i get the real people they're
real people they're real i got it Guys, I got it.
I just had to watch.
I just had to go to TSN.
Guys, I got it.
I got the live one.
All right, now I can see their faces.
Oh, someone got a yellow card in the South Africa.
So, my God, they're real people.
At the 70...
Okay, the time passes by real fast when you're like, oh my
God, I'm literally multi-viewing right now.
I'm like, the left side is the Korea versus South Africa
game.
versus, uh, Czech right now.
Like, I see their faces.
I can see them.
I'm no longer getting schemas.
I'm locked in.
All right.
Okay.
For Canada's sake, for Canada's sake, which team do we have
the best chance against, guys?
This is our first time qualifying to top 32, which, uh, I'm
football maxing right now.
I found...
So, do I want to...
The issue is, no, okay, so...
Okay, what was fucked up during...
When I was, like, there at the stadium is that we went in,
because, like, everybody was wearing red.
But the thing is, Switzerland and Canada, they're both red.
So, like, all the Swiss fans and all the...
Oh, we're wearing red, and all the Canadian fans were
wearing red.
as well so you couldn't tell which one was Switzerland and
which one was Canada and but then so the thing was you would
assume that Canada you would assume that Canada would be the
home team because we're in Canada and we're we're playing in
Canada and like you know we should get the right away like
Yeah, we should get them right away because we're literally
in our home country.
But then when we showed up, like when all of us showed up
there, we were red, you know, all the Canadians with the
red.
Kind of shows up in a white jersey as the way team.
And everyone was so confused because we were like, why are
they wearing white?
like the entire stadium was red because we all assume that
canada would be the home team and then canada walks up in
the white jersey because they are they be they were they
were dominated as the away team um during the last game
because we were in canada like also it was so funny because
like stadium i would assume the entire stadium was like 90
percent canadian um okay so i want south africa to win to
have a better chance i'm sorry korea i'm sorry to all my
koreans i'm sorry uh oh pistol korea papa oh pistol korea
papa i'm sorry korea as much as much as i have many bros and
homies in korea i i want canna to at least survive one game.
I'm sorry, Faker.
I'm so sorry.
You guys are too good.
You still qualify, Korea.
Remember, you still qualify.
This is our first time qualifying.
This is our first time up there.
We want to know what it's like to win at least one.
game I'm the community was just being polite letting the
Swiss wear their main color guys thank you super chat thank
you thank you you'll still be there no matter what you're
just you're always gonna beat that the next team but there's
there's we don't know if there's the next team for us we
don't know all
right I mean Mexico is definitely gonna win this one What is
gonna be our group stages?
What is, sorry, what is, what does our top 32 stage look
like?
Yeah, I'm reacting.
I didn't realize, but I didn't realize the games would still
be going on when I'm streaming.
Not gonna lie, I came back and was just like, I'll talk
about it.
Alright, I'll be like, why are we watching and South Korea
versus South Africa is the battle the selves which is is the
battle of the self right now also it was really funny
because um no i mean like if we pass if we in the qualifying
stage what what the our qualifying stage teams look like
best best self wins which self is more self exactly which
which self is more self than the other selves okay so it was
really funny because because like you know i'm sitting also
i'm so glad i got the hospitality seat it was so nice i
don't think like i don't think i could sit in the stands any
i'd like i've never sat in the regular stands because it was
just too good you know how it's like you could you can never
go back you know when you experience the good life you can't
go back so i skipped the stand life and went straight to
like the hospitality It was actually like it was like all
you can drink so I don't I don't have to leave like half
time or whatever I basically never left my area because they
had everything in my area So like basically like you know if
I'm thirsty I literally could go to the lounge.
I okay after I left I like took like five water bottles and
orange juice I was like, I see because I can and I have a
bag so I was just like I just like, I just went and grabbed
like all the free drinks to take home because I was just
like, I don't need to buy any more water for a while.
Oh yeah, it's all you can drink too.
So the bar, oh my gosh, the cups are so fancy.
Yeah, I was getting my money's worth.
And the bar was like, it was all you can drink alcohol as
well.
So they have like cocktails and like beer and stuff.
And also all you can eat.
There's an all you can eat buffet and it was good.
was all you can eat popcorn and all you can eat buffet and
um and you could stay at the lounge like after the game is
over because like i try to leave like the most because i
wanted to like check around walk around um yeah the one time
i left because i was just like i'm gonna buy it oh wait
someone's on a stretcher is that checks or look the the way
in home team jerseys always fuck me up Is that Czechs or
Mexico?
Sorry, now my teams are getting mixed up.
That got pulled away into the stretcher.
I'm listening to two commentaries at the same time.
That is not smart.
I'm multi-listening too.
It was Czechs Republic?
Oh, that's not good.
I'm multi-listening.
Left side is for Korea.
Right side is for Mexico.
Yeah.
the voices the voices I'm multi-track listening right now
all the voices right now
I wish I could I need to find better music to watch this by
the way it's too relaxing I had to like set up everything
super fast because my PC wasn't booting up for like it's
like a little gotcha if my PC decides to boot fast or boot
slow.
I've like, I played soccer.
I played soccer for like, since middle school to high
school.
And I played my, like, my teams got first place.
I was MVP.
Like, I've always enjoyed soccer.
I just, like, I think, like, World Cup is the only time,
like, it's really exciting to watch because it's very
patriotic.
But, like, also, Canada's always been asked at football
slash soccer.
So, like, I never had, like, that much passion for it and um
I remember when I was like um I did like I think like China
qualified during South Africa right uh China qualified
during um self the South Africa World Cup right because I
watched I remember watching I was watching that because you
know it's like super patriotic and everything you're like
yeah yeah World Cup is always like super hype uh or has
China never qualified.
I don't remember.
I know, like, in the Olympics, they've, like, qualified for
soccer, but I don't remember if they qualified during World
Cup.
When did China qualify?
Oh, China qualified in Japan.
Oh, okay.
I don't remember why I was watching the South Africa World
Cup then.
I think I remember.
I don't remember why I was watching South Africa.
I think it was just very hype because it was Shakira.
The Shakira song and then also the buvo cellas so um so I
don't know I don't know why I was super interested in the
World Cup back then um for the love of the game yeah I think
that was it I think it was like during my the peak of my
soccer career so I was like super interested in soccer so it
was like the right moment it was the right moment where uh
where i was very interested in soccer and i was like the
adrenaline of playing soccer made me watch more soccer stuff
so then i started watching it was the right time to watch
the vuvuzetas in south africa but then after that i stopped
paying attention to soccer i will have to say but the canada
one was really fun but because you know canada's part of the
qualified so now i'm like more engaged because i was like oh
you know you know before Before we won the Qatar game, no
one cared.
No, I didn't have no one in Canada can't.
I'm so sorry.
But, like, it was so sad.
Like, the Qatar versus Canada stadium was so empty before.
You guys have no idea.
Like, people were like, the mayor was like, had to, like,
beg people to come to watch the games in Vancouver because
of how bad it was.
And then Qatar was giving away tickets for free.
Yeah.
And so like, no one in Canada cared.
Because no one believed in Canada.
The Canadians, we Canadians didn't believe in Canada.
So like we didn't expect anything at all.
Yeah.
So when I bought the ticket, I said, this before when i
bought the ticket uh for uh for the canada versus
switzerland it wasn't even 50 percent sold the the stadium
was like i think 30 percent to 40 percent sold i think even
less maybe less i think it was 30 percent sold and there
were so many tickets and so i was just like i might as well
like for the experience because i don't think i'll ever
experience a world game in my own country for a while so I'd
like they made it for a long time I bought it the day the
day um before and uh and and then I was so surprised that
when that my ticket tripled in price the moment Qatar won
let me start at the moment Canada won against Qatar yeah
My ticket actually tripled in price when Canada beat Qatar
right like the day after and I and and then like um And then
when I got there, it was a fully packed stadium like every
seat I they literally put out the broadcast being like They
brought out a broadcast like I tweeted out being like it was
54,450 seats and it's all sold out like everything sold out
like every seat was just filled it was a full house and that
was insane yeah i was just like holy shit oh my god
oh shit that's crazy i got a ticket version of a graphics
card lolly thank you super chat thank you thank you my ocean
is a scalper let's go oh it's a Corner kick right now.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, I was so sad I didn't kick near my area so I could get a
free ball.
Oh!
That was close.
Oh, Korea almost got it.
That was so close.
Oh, if he hit that headshot, if he hit that headshot, sorry,
if he hit that headbutt, I'm sorry, my FPS terms are
blurring the lines right now.
That was crazy.
He literally, if he hit that headbutt, it would have gotten
a headshot.
I'm multi-watching, by the way.
I'm watching both games at the same time.
I can do this.
Oh, second chance, second chance.
Oh!
Goal!
Mexico!
Yeah!
No, Mexico.
I'm multi-drifting, guys.
You're like, which one is it?
Which one is she watching?
I told you, I can multi-drift.
I'm multi-tracking right now.
It was Mexico.
Oh my gosh, it's a 3-0.
Yeah!
Viva Mexico!
That was crazy.
Oh my god, the goalkeeper tried so hard too.
He blocked the first shot, and it was the second shot that
got in.
Where is the stadium right now for Mexico?
Oh, they're lucky.
They get to play on home turf.
Can't let's go to LA.
I don't want Bado looking for a website to watch it on.
So now I'm listening to Dokey Bird Sports Radio.
Don't welcome.
I don't know this might be the only time you get this
Because I don't I I'm worried about watching Canada getting
his ass beat Maybe I'll watch the Canada games maybe it's
pretty exciting
Yeah, Mexico.
You're so lucky we have to go to LA We have to go to LA I
think it's fucked that when the home Country or like not I
guess it's because it's just rules because it doesn't it
doesn't matter what placement they get but like Canada has
to leave their home turf one more minute unless Korea does a
miracle goal so we might fight South Africa at least like
Korea at least Korea still qualifies though who did the 8th
court fight
oh 30 seconds 30 seconds
not clear yet no not clear yet clear who korea is gonna play
against wait there's no wait korea might not make it why
wait why they've always they've majority of time caught
they're so good korea is like everyone in in high school
middle school like all the koreans were so into soccer they
were like they would always oh south africa Africa
qualifies.
Are...
Mexico...
Oh...
Oh, no!
No!
Wait, does Korea not have enough points?
The huge upset?
No, we are fighting South...
Oh, we are fighting South Africa.
Yeah, we're fighting South Africa.
playing against South Africa.
Alright.
No, really?
That's crazy.
South Africa is always...
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
The South's is messing me up.
What a coincidence.
South Africa versus South Korea.
No way!
Korea, FIFA, World Cup.
They've always...
The majority of the time, qualified.
Yeah.
They've qualified for the last 30 years.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Yeah, like, the last 10 years, they've qualified.
Or not, sorry, the last 10 FIFA's.
Or not 10 years.
10 FIFA's, they've always qualified.
They've always been, like, insane at ensuring the World Cup.
There's no way they don't qualify.
What's the...
Uh,
yeah, World Cup.
Um, what's the...
Oh, my God.
There's the Mexico-Canada group.
There they are.
What's the...
Did they get a hard, super hard group stage?
So...
Was there a group, the deaf group?
It's like eSports.
It's like eSports, or it's like there's a deaf group.
So, has it been like fully confirmed eliminated?
Or is it fully confirmed eliminated?
Or do they have to wait for one more game?
Yeah, I saw.
We all saw it.
They have to wait.
So, who's the team that's decided on?
Japan was a deaf group Alright let me look at it Japan FIFA
World Cup
Which one Which team are they waiting on So Japan They have
to Japan has to win against Sweden To For Korea to qualify
I don't understand like the point system That's the thing I
don't understand That's what I'm learning about because it's
like because I don't I thought like it's like from their
groups alone you just didn't work out to need to wait for
the rest of the games to conclude and hope they stay in a
position to qualify for the round of 32 okay so yeah I
thought it was two teams per group so shouldn't South Korea
be out already oh the best eight team from all the third
places qualify Oh, I see.
Okay, yeah, that makes more sense.
So, because I was like, well, isn't it top two from each
group?
So if it's top two from each group, then, like, Korea should
be automatically out.
But now that there's, they have to draw 10, 8 more teams
from the third.
Okay, I get it now.
I get it.
Naruto.
Yeah, so there's, like, yeah, the wild card spot.
Um, I understand.
So it's, it's like,
Oh, oh.
Oh, is that new?
Did they implement that like for this year?
I want to show you guys a funny clip.
I didn't realize that that's what happened.
Okay, let me, I'll show you.
I need to find like a FIFA, uh, no copyright music song.
I need to find one because it feels weird to listen to this
when I talk about FIFA.
Maybe I can, maybe I have one here.
I'm pretty sure I have like a BGM that we can put in.
all right what is oh finally after not that not that it says
bgm anniversary and it was a fucking video and i was like
that's not what i wanted maybe i shouldn't gamma this maybe
i'm worried now i'm worried because like all right so i
clearly i don't name things correctly uh Like, you name, you
put your DVD, like, back in the day, when you have, like,
PlayStation games, and then you put the wrong disc in the
wrong box, because you're like, oh, that's the closest box
to me.
That's basically what I did.
No, that was from last year.
That was the last year, fake out.
The last year's 3D debut fake out.
Okay, maybe this.
okay this is one minute of this i don't think that's gonna
work for me i feel like we're gonna get tired of that song
what about this okay that has lyrics in there we don't want
that
we don't want lyrics all right wait all right i need to use
the bathroom real quick i'll be right back guys i need to go
pee i'll be right back
sorry i had to pee real quick all right uh oh yeah because
there's no music these are so quiet hvn smoky vincent nexi
papa bite many onya uh four solid alan they have a super
chat thank you thank you let me see if i can find some music
for us real fast i need some some hype FIFA music with no
lyrics all right this does this this does not look very
hyped trying to find some hyped sports songs I need
something I need to get that energy up like I'm playing
football right now oh this one all right this might be it i
found one oh i feel like i'm in the stadium right now okay
let me download this real quick download youtube music all
right i think i found it click here to download
that oh my god i almost dax and then oh my god i almost got
me You know, the fake download button, it almost got me.
I think they almost did it.
They almost got me.
All right, here we go.
They're like, click here, and it was not there.
This was not that button that I should have clicked.
All right, let me add this.
Media, loop, download.
Yeah!
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry, this always happens.
Yeah, now we're FIFAing.
Okay, let me get rid of.
All right, let me see.
Okay, I need to get, like, hype chat overlays.
YouTube chat overlay.
I need to feel like I'm there.
Bye-bye.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, let me see if I can find, like, a FIFA chat
overlay.
Well, obviously, it won't be FIFA-related, but, you know,
like, something that feels like I'm not in an alley right
now.
Not in an alley.
Welcome to Doki.
Oh, wait.
I know which one to use.
I don't know which one.
See, it should be browser.
It's not birthday.
Where is it?
What did I call it?
News.
There we go.
Yeah!
Now we're FIFAing!
okay wait wait wait and then we need the image what was it
called it's not that picture what is the chat inner chair
concept green screen oh my god inner It has to be no, that's
interview background.
Oh my god, what is it?
Was it called?
What was it?
What oh, yeah, I forgot it has it did at the cropping here.
Okay, we're gonna go to All right, let's see.
I think it was like, no, that's Where's the interview This
thing I made a while ago?
I need to find like the picture for it Winner announce a
party star what the fuck is the interview i i didn't name my
stuff better you know it's called football because you play
with your feet a little fun fact for you well thank you for
the super chat no really no way next you're gonna tell me
next you're gonna tell me handball is played with your hands
that's crazy i'm i i don't believe you I don't believe you
all right I'm gonna okay I don't know if it's this oh wait
not this okay is it party start no that's not it I'm so
confused it's cheapy is it this no that's not it maybe is
this is it this no that's not it that's I guess I need to
name my stuff better I literally I'm so confused what my
things are I'm so confused where was I was here there is no
way I'm trying to find it guys I'm trying to find it you
remember where I put the picture okay it's not this it's not
that I have too many I will say I do have too many scenes
and I don't name them very well So I get very confused.
We went everywhere.
We're traveling around the world in 80 days.
It's not that one.
That's not it either.
Wait, did I...
Where is it, though?
Where did I put it?
It's not that.
It's not...
I know it's not this.
Oh, it's this.
There, I found it.
Okay.
What is this called?
What was...
Okay, that's not...
Okay, we're gonna get rid of that.
That was for the concert, guys.
Yes, there is.
Okay, there's the chair.
So this?
No, that's the background.
Where was this for?
Okay.
That's the overlay.
Oh, there we go.
I found it.
It's all in Japanese.
But I found it, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna rename this.
Interview chat.
background.
Alright.
Alright, I found it.
Alright, back to the... Back to the stadium, guys.
I found it, everybody.
Alright.
I found it.
Okay.
Wait, what did I name it?
It was interview.
Okay.
There we go.
I found it.
Alright.
Now!
Now we're FIFA-ing.
Now we're...
We figured it out, guys.
Now we're FIFAing, guys.
For real.
I'm very organized.
I am a very organized person.
And let me actually move this a little bit down, maybe.
Oh, not that.
Nope, not that.
This.
Okay.
I'll put this a little bit down.
And then, actually, I can't put that down, actually.
Whoa.
So, I'm so organized.
All right, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Wait, why am I doing that when I can just resize this?
There we go.
Everything works out.
Now, oh, wait.
I wanted, the whole idea was I wanted to move this down.
And then, there we go.
It all works out now.
Actually, I could make this a little bigger.
All right, we're good.
Professional streamer.
Back from World Cup.
All right, so, let me look at my notes real quick.
All right, so for those who didn't know, I was at the
stadium for Canada versus Switzerland um and uh you know we
are I was a little worried because I thought that like um I
thought that we weren't if we lose we weren't gonna qualify
but everything's fine we qualified or the craziest the
funniest part was that it would always do the you know like
an announcement ping but like you're like you know when
you're like at school and then it's like the lunch for
today's menu is but they do that for like whenever uh the
other team like whenever like the other team like the Bosnia
versus Qatar game when Bosnia scored a goal so you know for
those who didn't know yeah the FIFA jingle uh during the
first half nothing happened during the during the first half
it was just like it was like and it's like Bosnia scored
another goal yeah it's like a PA announcement and he's like
Bosnia scored another goal for like the first 45 minutes or
for the first 50 minutes like nothing happened nothing
happened in the canada versus switzerland but all you would
hear was like you scored another goal you scored another
goal well i just stopped switzerland canada fucking just a
stalemate for like nothing was happening Like, Switzerland
just kept passing the ball, and the worst part, okay, the
worst part was on my side.
The side I was on, the first game was Switzerland, was near
my half of the side.
So, yeah, the first half was not that exciting, but, like,
it will say, even so, um, even so, I was like, um, the time
passes by so quickly when you're like, at the stadium
watching the game it felt I didn't even realize 45 minutes
passed when I was there I feel like it just it was just gone
I was literally just gone I think it really helped that my
seat was so comfortable too
Jonesy food they even this I also had a table in front of me
too because that's like yeah hospitality tickets baby I had
a table to put my drink my free drinks and free food.
I was like, I did enjoy that.
I really, I really did enjoy that.
I was at the Bosnia versus Qatar game waiting for the
Canadians to get that chime going.
Yeah, unfortunately, it was not the Canadians that got the
chime going.
Elle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't even know.
It was absent due to working more than 10 hours I also don't
recommend drinking.
Yeah, that's not healthy at all.
L.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you're okay.
Thank you.
Um, don't worry.
You can live, you can live by curiously through me.
I'm sharing the experience.
So it's like your, but the thing is mine wasn't even the V
VIP or the V VIP.
I was just VIP.
There was like three other tiers above my seat tier.
Just so you guys know, there were three other tiers above
me.
I mean, I was, I would, I wanted to buy it, but they were
sold out.
So I only bought the remaining VIP tickets left.
So it was like, it was the second best VIP ticket you can
get.
So I'm not sorry, it's not second.
It was the second last VIP ticket here.
So the first, second, and third are more expensive and like
they're even fancier.
I heard, I don't know if it's true.
Wait, let me look it up.
I'm going to look it up because I don't want to spread false
information.
Let me look it up to see if he's actually, he was actually
there.
Let's see.
Never mind.
He was not there.
I thought he was there.
Someone said he was there.
And I was just like, he's there?
I there's no way he was there.
I was going to say, like, Australia's not even in our...
Okay, someone was like, yeah, Hugh, they...
Yeah, Hugh Jackson.
here I was like there's no way there's no way Hugh Jackman
is here there's no there's no way Australia is not even like
where we're at I'm pretty sure Hugh Jackman the guy who
plays Wolverine no way I'm pretty sure there were famous
people there but it was definitely not Hugh Jackman.
There's no way.
Was he actually there?
No, don't say that.
Canada.
I heard someone saying that Hugh Jackman was here for our
game, but I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's true.
it could be I mean okay so all right so the funny thing is I
could I almost could I could have sneaked into the the VV
VIP room because in the VV VIP section is where you can take
if you have the general via if you have any of the VIP tiers
um oh were they wait are you See, I could have, oh my god.
Wait.
Nuts, I should have sneaked in.
Oh my god, I could have, they had to be in the VV VIP rooms.
They, they must have been in the VV VIP rooms.
Oh my god, I was a coward because I was a fucking coward.
miss my chest no okay so um let me see i got i took a photo
let me pull it up um let me pull up the photo i mean i i
could have met deadfoot and wolverine oh my god
photo guys okay it's a little blurry but all right so it's a
little blurry so we're just gonna take it what we can get um
give me a sec
all right i'm saving this picture all right let me grab the
photo real quick it's loading okay so for those who don't
know all right so you guys can't see that that's a pf world
cup trophy um so um the thing is for uh so it was halftime
also that's what that was also why i was late for halftime
so uh so for half time um oh that's the pfa world cup that's
the pfa world cup trophy behind me but it's literally It's
literally in the VV VIP area.
And when you get your VIP, just whatever VIP ticket you get,
you get to wear the bracelet.
But the top part, everyone's the same.
So on the bracelet, the top is the same, but the bottom has
the different colors to tell what tier you're in.
So obviously, when I'm showing my bracelet, you can only see
the top.
So you can't see the bottom.
You can't, you can't see the bottom.
So, um, so when, when I went in, when I went in, I literally
just flashed it and they let me through the first door
because I wanted to take a photo of the trophy.
Like, so, so they're like, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, you're
definitely, you're, you're part of the VV VIP.
Oh, it is a music loud, I'm so sorry.
turn it down oh my god was it loud the entire time i didn't
realize i'm so sorry guys let me turn it down so because
only the only the vv vip uh ticket holders could take a
picture of the trophy
so so i didn't know that we saw a lot of people heading in
and i thought i was trying to go to the fifa store to buy
buy a jersey I was I was trying to go to the I wanted I was
trying to find the fifa store and the lady was like Oh it's
in gate A But she meant gate H So I went in I was like oh
that's Gate A because she was talking she's saying Gate she
mispronounced H and it sounded like A So I went to I didn't
realize Gate A was the VVV IP area so I was just like oh
okay and I flashed it and I was like where is it and I saw
the trophy and everyone was lining up uh to take pictures of
the trophy and so I was like I might as well I'm here and I
realized wait a minute I'm not supposed to be here because I
noticed everyone surrounding me I was not in their tax
bracket I was like I was like oh my god these people are so
rich like you there's like you know like when they're really
really really fucking rich and you can instantly tell with
like how the aura and like what they're like I could feel
the wealth and I was literally like they were all taking
photos with the trophy and everything and I was just like I
do not belong here I like these people are like
multi-millionaire billionaires and I'm just Like, I do not,
it's just like, I could smell the trust fund babies and the
multi-billionaire, like business owners.
I felt the class difference.
So they're all, they're all just like, they were all just
like taking pictures and like what they are wearing and like
just like the air around them.
and then because they're coming out of the room because i
see the room and i saw them they were not checking the bands
at all because you already bypassed the first security so
they're just like yeah so they were like people were just
taking the photo and then going back into the room so i was
just like i could go in i could i could go in just to see
what it's like in there see the tier room at the oh she cats
to the billion sir curiously papa smirthing you with a super
chat thank you thank you i i could see like just like buy
like a so i could just buy a so see just like feel what it's
like to be like them so so because i see them they would
take the photo they're all taking photos and stuff of of the
trophy and then and then going back in and like the guard
like the they weren't checking the tags anymore because like
the main security because I just flashed my tag because I
was wearing my tag so it's wearing my tag so they just saw
that and just said she's VIP but like I'm not v v vip though
mine was like the second last VIP tier this was the number
one VI VIP yeah no there's they there is security but
they're mostly just just checking the bracelets they weren't
checking like they weren't checking like the box because
it's the bottom of the bracelet that had the colors like you
know they color coded us like you know you know classism
does exist so they color coded us with the bottom of the
bracelet but they were always looking at the top of the
bracelet not the bottom of the bracelet because i could just
have my pen um in my like just on my pocket or something and
like just show and they're like oh she's it like obviously
yeah like oh she has a bracelet like yeah the bottom of the
top one percent i just had to walk in there with confidence
like i i could have met i could have met ryan reynolds and
hugh jackman they must have been in that room they were
obviously in that room yeah so oh i uh anyway i did not
sneak in because i chickened out at the last second i got
really worried um i was like oh man i i chickened out at the
last moment because i was just like didn't want to get in
trouble i didn't want to get kicked out because then if i
get caught it'd be really really bad of no i i was on
purpose trying to get into that room like it wasn't like
like oopsie i got lost you know what they would know i
wasn't being like being like whoops sorry i got lost
so so i did not i did not try to sneak into the vv vip room
oh wait i'll let me show you a blurry picture of the trophy
by the way let me show it to you but that was also why i was
two minutes late to the uh to the fucking oh my god i was so
i was so mad because i it felt like here's the non-blurry
photo of this so basically uh uh basically uh what happened
was I wanted to buy the Canadian jersey, which was a hundred
fucking dollars, by the way.
That is not worth a hundred dollars, but I was just like,
you know, I was just like, I'm here.
It would be a good souvenir.
And, you know, it's literally, you know, Candace's first
time qualifying and out of the group stages.
So I was like, I was just like in my head, I was just, I was
coping, trying to justify the cost because I was just like,
Candace first time is like a part of history.
You know, I'm owning a merch that's part of history.
okay i'm gonna buy it like like anyway and then i went back
to my lounge to my seat and it was one zero and i was just
like what what happened i by the way the game was only
running for two minutes legit like i first up nothing
happened like it had nothing fucking happened in the first
half of the game like i was just watching switzerland pass
the ball for the 100th time during the first half just to
see one zero after no i got the jersey i bought the jersey i
got the jersey i spent a hundred dollars just to come back
to see switzerland score to see missed out on switzerland's
goal dude thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
like i was just like what happened stop sorry mr reynolds
i'm lost king draw me a map and sign it and put with love
for doky oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
yeah and then no legitimately okay every time okay like i
think this was the uh the funniest part when you're like
your home home advantage and um every time switzerland had
the ball like that was like when we're doing their 120th
passing at the at the goalkeeper place area when they were
doing that like they passed for the 120th time by the way
they counted the passes i feel like that was just so passive
aggressive i like live for that so at one point during after
halftime during like i don't know maybe it was like the 50th
minute or the 60th minute of the game um it flashed on the
screen on the top of the screen it was like switzerland 150
passes canada 40 passes because that was all they were doing
they were so like the stack counters were so petty they're
like just keep passing i guess saw like 150 passes from
Switzerland 40 passes from Canada yeah like the fucking
stats like even they know yeah damn y'all just let them pass
the ball all game no that's literally what that was
literally first half and then every time it happened because
it's what they do it would just pass to a goalkeeper
goalkeeper pass to the guy on the right defender defender
passes back to the goalkeeper passes to left defender left
defender passes to send midfield midfield passes back to
right defender right defender passes to left defender left
defender passes back to the goalkeeper that's that was the
first half and then you canada would be like like it's all
you hurt it was canada be like like um
Yeah, the salt strap.
And then it's literally...
Yeah, it's just boo!
And I was on that side, like the side where...
Yeah, just like, do something.
Play some fucking football.
I didn't boo.
I thought it was just so fucking funny.
And the thing is, the first half, Switzerland was on my
side.
So you guys can see here.
You guys see here, Switzerland fly.
lag is on the site that was my side that was sitting on so
you know i was like oh my god can't wait to see some fucking
goals um on my side like you know like you know i see you
know canna shoot score some goals close up on my side
instead i just see like i just see switzerland play like hot
potato for like 30 minutes like and everyone on my my all
the all like the fans on my side were like boo
so yes that's really what it was like and in the second half
wow the moment they scored i have to watch my team fucking
fumble it during when they're finally on my side and when
they actually score goals they're like 80 miles away from me
and i was like they scored
They were so fine.
So I was just like when they scored I was like
Yeah, I yeah, I caught the second I yeah, I saw the second
goal Yeah, I also saw them celebrating in front of me like
right in front of my face Yeah Okay, to be fair they weren't
that far, but it's also you know like They are further away
from me.
Like the perspective is a little harder to see versus them
being next to me.
So, what a goal by promise in Saliba.
Swiss also kicked the daylights out of Canada.
What a dude.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Switzerland had really good defense.
Like I swear to God, like when they were on ours, like when
Swiss was on my side, Um, I it was literally like three
people were just crowding around one guy and like he
couldn't do anything I felt like I was just like this is
like I I was like they have a really good goalkeeper and it
was okay It was like so Like the guy was so fucking good the
goalkeeper was so good in Switzerland side I felt like he
like Canada took so many shots and like he just saved a
majority of them And it was crazy because the last 20
seconds, oh my, if he, if Canada scored, that would have
been absolute cinema.
But like he actually, the guy caught the ball and then he
fucking injured himself for it too.
Like you would see him like, he was like on the ground and I
was like, what happened?
Is he like, I was just like, what the fuck happened over
there?
Like last 20 seconds, the guy actually like, like hard
injured himself.
really fucking good, like watching him play.
Like, he legitimately, like, saved, like, he saved 99% of
the shots.
And the last 20 seconds was fucking crazy.
And then you see, like, kind of, like, in the scene.
I mean, it was like, whoa!
Um, oh, yeah, wait, I have to show you guys this.
Because I didn't know what happened.
Because, you know, we don't have the close-up cams.
Like, you, like, people who are watching TV, you know?
People who are watching on TV, they know what was going on.
but I did I like you know I'm watching from like like it was
pretty close up it was still close up because it was still
up like it was a hospitality seat um and we had like tables
and stuff but um you know like when they're like at midfield
it's still like you can't see the fine details of what the
fuck is going on you see a guy on the floor you know you're
just like oh my god riff why and then why you do that why
did you give him a yellow car What did he do?
He's on the fucking floor So like there was an instance
where two for one of the Canadian guys was on the floor But
then but and you know and then the guy that kicked him got
the yellow card But then but also I didn't want to wash with
binoculars I think that's I think it was fine.
I had a great experience But then suddenly the ref gave the
guy on the floor a yellow card as well And then we saw like
and then like you know like all like everyone in the stadium
was Like, boo!
Like, what?
What the fuck, Rapp?
Like, everyone in the stairs, like, boo!
Like, and I was just like, what's, the, why, why did it
give, because, like, even the Canadian players were really
mad.
Like, they pushed one of the Switzerland players, um,
because they were like, why?
Like, like, and I was, and then everyone was like, yeah, why
did he get it?
Yeah, he's on the floor.
Why did he get a yellow card?
And then I saw the gift.
Oh my god.
No, they got copyright strike.
I should have saved that gift.
It was so funny.
Oh my god.
Wait, let me see if I can find the Canada.
I need to find it.
It was like it was someone in the thing.
It was like someone was like that's so dominant.
It was so fucking funny.
I saw a gift of it on Twitter.
I was like, oh, that's what happened.
happen.
I was just like, that's what, okay, that makes more sense.
All right.
Okay, so, okay, I found it.
But, okay, this is basically what happened.
So, the guy, it's so funny.
I was just like, I was just like, so he was not supposed to
kick the ball.
By the way, the Canada is the one the white jersey and he's
not supposed to kick that ball So he did it anyway, so he
got kicked because the guy was trying to kick the ball Like
Oh, it's region locked.
Okay, don't worry.
I got you guys.
Oh, wait, I don't want to get Guys, I don't want to get hit
by I don't want to get hit by by FIFA guys.
Oh my Oh my god, okay, I wish I, let me see if I can find
something that's not region-like.
Let me see.
I'm gonna try and find a gift, okay.
Um, I'm trying to find a gift that's not region-like because
I can't, guys, I don't want to get in trouble, you guys.
Oh, it's TSN, so.
Don't, don't, that's why I'm not downloading it.
I'm not downloading the video.
I'm trying, oh my god, everyone's like, the video's not
available in your location.
I heard XQC got like a timeout on um a timeout like got like
uh suspended for a little timeout because he watched a
little bit of like what's her what's his name Mbappe you
watched a little bit of it yeah we're a five second clip I
don't want to be next guys oh my okay I'll I'll draw it for
you I'll illustrate it.
Oh, you found one?
Gerald, give me the Twitter username.
Give me the Twitter username.
Yeah, TSN is the Canadian ESPN.
Gerald, give it to me.
Got it.
Gerald, I need the Twitter handle.
Oh my god, Gerald disappeared.
FIFA got him.
I was going to say, did FIFA...
forgot him?
Jail, please.
We need the clip.
I was like, they got him.
Guys, they got him.
All right, let me see if I can find it.
How many hours ago was it?
All right, is there like, okay, here.
All right, this is not the right angle.
All right, but okay, I will say the angle was even funnier.
In the Canadian broadcast, it's even funnier In the Canadian
broadcast of it Because it's like the angle was so fucking
funny It's It was really funny So what happened was
basically It was a free kick, and Canada was not supposed to
touch the ball during that.
So obviously, he just, he literally just like, no, like, he
just, he just like, and then my leg!
And he got kicked because he was trying to, the Swiss player
was trying to free kick, and then Canada literally just
moved the ball away.
like it's just he's just being a little silly and someone
like this is like some fucking Tommy Jerry shit right there
like um Merck they give us super chat thank you thank you
there's freedom speech but cannot guarantee freedom after
speech they give us a super chat thank you thank you so so
but then the thing is the
Like, we in the stadium can see that, you know?
Like, we're, we don't have the close-up of that.
So I didn't know that's what happened.
And everyone was so mad in the stadium.
Because they were like, everyone was booing at the ref.
Because they're like, he's on the floor, bro.
Like, why did he get, why did he get a yellow card?
It was like, boo!
And then I looked at Twitter and I was just like, oh shit,
wait, that's what happened?
Like, I was just like, oh man, okay, that makes more sense
now.
I was just like, oh, wait, I get it now.
Yeah, oh, that's why.
Because I was wondering, I was like, why did the guy on the
floor get a yellow card?
bro like what what is he like do you get a yellow card
because he couldn't stand up like like he didn't stand up in
time is that is that it like i'm so wait is this region
locked this is the other angle is this one region locked
guys but it was really funny i was just i thought that
little toddy poop too like yellow carver being a big baby
man like oh i'm lucky this region locked unlucky it was but
like i wanted to see how i could grab the pov for you guys
but i don't want to get struck down by fifa yes i'm scared
i'm i'm i'm too much yeah can this particular Canadian,
yeah, I can watch it, though.
I can't, no, it's okay, I already gave the other angle.
I already gave the different angle for it, but it's
literally that, but it's the same.
It's literally that, but it was a different angle.
Wait, what about this?
Wait, I got it.
Wait, how about this one?
The two can't be.
I got it, guys.
I found my angle.
this one this is funnier this is funnier this angle is so
much funnier like i love it so much funnier the the this is
the one i was talking about a little boom i'm sorry i don't
i'm like focusing on this one particular moment but it's so
funny though when i'm like see how like see it when i see
what happened actually it's just so fucking stupid it's yeah
I told you it's so funny like it's so funny it didn't work
yeah he's like why did you kick the ball because he's just
like because he's like What the fuck?
Why do I, what?
He's not supposed to kick the ball.
Like, why did he do that?
Bro.
Yeah, bro.
But anyway, like, so I really wanted to, I really wanted to
talk about that moment because I think that was the funniest
moment during that entire game.
What is this guy doing?
I posted the version on the live tag.
I'll take the risk, Doug.
It was nice knowing you.
Oh, seven.
It gets funnier every time I see a new angle.
It was nice knowing you, Doug.
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So I saw that happen, but I didn't get the context.
until I saw it on Twitter because like, oh, and then every
time um, every time like, uh, Switzerland had, like, it was
like, I had a corner cake or any, or anything.
It was so funny.
Like, whichever corner Switzerland was in, like, that side
would just be like, boo!
So maybe we get like the loudest boo, like the guy doing the
corner cake for Switzerland.
He would get the loudest booze.
Like and it would just be that corner.
So like all the booze would follow them around the corner
kick areas And they'll be like boo and then like, you know
the rest of the side there won't be booze But it would just
be the corner like wherever Switzerland was in like I just
thought it was so funny like that's a football like It was
so fucking funny you see like boo
you couldn't tell which one were the swiss fans and which
were the canadian fans because everyone was just wearing red
like the binaural booze yeah it was so loud oh my um the
booze were so fucking loud it was crazy how loud it was like
it's a whole like watching from the stadium versus watching
on tv is such a different experience i was not prepared for
it because i've never Like I said, I've never watched a game
in the stadium before.
And, uh...
And also, like...
Like, the audio for it was fucking crazy.
It was such a crazy experience in general.
Um...
I'm gonna get more water.
I'll be right back.
Wow!
Thank you for... Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, what else?
What else?
I wrote some stuff down.
Let me...
Uh... Oh, hey.
let's see oops sorry let me do new messages about stuff so I
have a so I have a tournament on Friday I can't say what it
is it's apparently I can't talk about the tournament because
I'm told we're told that we can't talk about the tournament
until people are announced and stuff until the teams are
announced and I saw a lot of drama about some about about it
because they're like why aren't they why aren't people
talking about the tournament I'm like we are not allowed to
talk about that we're in it like
and then someone someone talked about that they're in it and
then I saw that their tweet was deleted yeah because I think
they got in trouble I'm pretty sure they got in trouble
because we were told we're not allowed to say we're in it
like we're not And I because I saw it in the morning when I
woke up I was like wait, how come they get to talk about
being in it?
And then when I left the stadium the tweet was deleted They
got him like
Yeah Yeah, so it's not like we don't want to talk about it
We're just allowed to talk about it until they bounce it
like Yeah Anyway, let me see it All right, let me go check
something real quick
Also, I thought it was like I can't I can't say it I won't
I'll say it more about it later when the thing gets
announced I'll say I'll talk about it say it i'll say it
more about it later when the thing gets announced
i just thought it was so funny anyway what was i gonna say i
needed to what was i gonna say ah oh yeah i was gonna look
at my notes oh my god did you guys know that uh the refs the
refs have like dash cams now for like, I didn't even notice
that because like I saw on the screen there, like there was
like the referee dash cam and I thought it was so funny
because I make sure you know, everything is like accurate so
they have dash cams down I was like, I thought it was so
funny like I feel like what's next like the players are
going to get dash cams too to make sure like they're not
faking it yeah yeah the ref cam yeah they have a they have
like a body cam on their body like the referees and stuff
yeah sorry i meant body cams not dash cams body cams on
there on like attached to their bodies so they can see it
like yeah yeah first person referee you know yeah the reps
are cars they're not real people they don't have rights
hates the referees.
It's a fake-less job.
They can never, they can never get a call right or not.
It's actually a thankless job.
It is a pretty cool angle for goals.
I I'm just so sad that the first half that like they didn't
score anything and that was the closest they're near me.
Like I'm so I'm so sad that like, and then when they scored
a goal They're like they're on the other fucking side of the
field So I like the only POV I get was when we get scored on
Mr. Broken Bond Thank you, thank you, thank you It's a
tournament history fight I think you'll know I think you'll
like I think it'll be announced tomorrow I'm pretty sure It
has to be announced by tomorrow Because then it'll be the
day before the tournament They give us super chat, thank
you, thank you Um Bobobobo all right what else what that one
talk about uh oh yeah apparently um oh i wanted to wait i
wanted to show you yeah it's it was so cool during like like
okay like you obviously there was not a lot of swiss people
at the stadium i think just canadians bought out the stadium
in general so when the swiss national anthem was playing you
did not hear no like i'm pretty people were singing were
seeing it but like you can't hear it because it was just
drowned out by the Canadians that were there there was like
one corner that was all Swiss people because like you know
when Switzerland won in the end you see like one aisle where
everyone's just dancing and then everyone else was leaving
like but you can't tell because everyone was wearing red.
You didn't know which side, which were the Swiss.
You can't tell because we were all wearing red.
Like the only way we could tell was when there were like
when you saw the flag.
Like yeah.
Because like I can't tell.
We all wore red.
so the moment when the game finally ended i could tell where
the swiss fans were because like they were the ones that
were dancing and celebrating but like literally like it was
like they had like the one aisle that's all like swiss fans
and they're all dancing me like we won um yeah or they wear
white as well like because we're like oh let's be like we're
both red and white like i didn't know which one is swiss and
which one's canadian like yeah so obviously like on tv it's
very easy but when you're there it is it's like where's wall
though like where's where which worst can the worst the
swiss like so so but yeah like you tell that you i found out
like oh wait that's the aisle where all the swiss people are
because they were all dancing and then like literally like
the surrounding aisles were just people leaving like i
thought it was so funny like they're all like yeah and then
the aisles surrounding them were all leaving because they're
like oh game's over can the loss i go now i that was so that
was really funny just seeing that in person um okay i found
the video uh let me see i can i use this one all right
that's a movie clip so let's see oh wait did i not download
it i thought i downloaded a video i wanted to show you it
was so cool seeing like this in person all right let me
download this real quick uh all right here you go i showed
this on twitter but i thought it was just really cool in
general why did you sing Canada
I just wanted it like I wanted the aesthetically pleasing I
sang it in my heart I just I wanted the video to be like
cool okay Canada they
I don't know why I'm not supposed to tell And so I can't
handle loss.
I can't.
There's no reason.
Candle loss.
She didn't sing the Canadian national anthem.
Yeah, no.
They're there.
Join.
I think it was super chat.
I do take notes.
I take notes just because like, just to remember like every
moment that I thought was funny or like interesting to talk
about.
Because obviously I can't remember.
It was a long day.
I can't remember at the end, you know?
Yeah, those Swiss fans are wearing white and red.
Well, the Canadian fans are wearing red and white, Doki.
God, it's so easy to tell.
it's so easy to tell.
It's so easy to tell, yeah.
um but yeah wait i did take a picture of this give me a sec
let me see oh i didn't send it to my set let me send that uh
but like i said it was such a cool like just hearing
everyone also singing the national anthem to canada like it
was such a cool experience like like being in that scene
when we when we score a goal we're like oh you know that one
goal that we scored we're like oh
Like, it's like a Sonic boom, you know?
So, Koa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, I started stream, talked about Mexico, and then
Mexico scored.
I mean, coincidence?
I think not.
That was a crazy goal.
It was.
It was a pretty insane goal, I will say.
Um, what else?
What else did I want?
Oh, yeah.
Um, it was so many people.
Holy shit.
That was a lot of people.
people um i'm an honoring mexican as from like uh from the
other from that mexican lady she gave me honoring mexican
status let's see i'm trying to find the photo oh wait where
is it where it said like it's like 54 000 i was like jesus
christ what uh where's walter Possible, Mr. Broken Bond.
Needless to reach out.
Thank you.
There it is.
Let me save this picture.
I'm sending it to my cell.
All right, here's some more photos, guys.
Here's some more FIFA World Cup photos.
Whoops.
So after the game, they all, like, sat down there for photos
and cameras.
And then King Canada is just there because there's...
leaving.
I did it.
That was really cool.
But, yeah, they were doing photos and like, they were just
doing photos and interviews and stuff at the side.
And then, like, I think there was also some, a Swiss aisle
there too.
I think, like, they sat there on purpose because there were,
uh, Swiss, there was a Swiss aisle as well on that corner.
Um, so, because there were a lot of them were like, You know
when they got closer so I'm pretty sure like they sat in
that corner just to be like yeah We did it for you
switzerland like the swiss people yeah You know, I know that
was why they were sitting there.
What else.
Oh, yeah, so
Let me see Oh, and then this picture I thought this was the
this is really cool after halftime a little bit uh it was
they brought they showed this broadcast saying that all
52,497 seats uh were sold out um so like that was how many
people there were there at the stadium but when i bought the
ticket it was like barely um it was like you know not a lot
of tickets were sold Let me say it was very easy to grab a
ticket
It was pretty easy to grab a ticket So to find out that To
find out that like, you know It ended up being sold out You
can see like these are not seats These are real people
sitting there Look, look, find the Swiss fan
These are not chairs, by the way.
These are not chairs.
Find a Swiss fan for me.
Like, he's over there.
Like, I found one.
He's, like, top left 33rd row.
That was...
Middle top, don't you see the cross right there?
It's just red and white.
I don't know.
How am I supposed to know?
We all wear the same colors.
Really worse, Waldo.
I bet the red team won.
That's why it's all red.
It's not an empty chair.
It's just everybody wearing red or white Mostly red Because
we I don't know we thought that we thought that Canada was
gonna wear red, I guess But I guess we were wrong We didn't
get the memo that they're gonna wear white Even our fucking
jerseys red Like you can't buy a white jersey by the way I
looked I looked at the store It was all red jersey so I
can't I was just Set up from the start.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's no white jersey you can buy.
We're just set up from the start.
We only have red.
We have to grab a white shirt, I guess.
Yeah, we lost the 50-50.
Also, Every time a wave, I'm so sorry, but every time, um,
every time there was the wave, it failed halfway.
It failed halfway.
I like, I was waiting for the wave to come over to me, and
then it died.
And it's like, like twice.
I was like, I'll never do the wave.
I'll never do the wave.
It like barely dies before it gets to me and it doesn't even
make it to me And I think you never got to be a part of the
wave I wanted to be a part of it
Someone said like Mexico had to wear a white shirt.
Yeah, but the Mexican fans wore white They wore white fair
it's not fair at all all right what else what else where
whoa no no he's just looking at me all right wait i'm gonna
use the bathroom i'm sorry i hydrated a lot it was a long
day to i'll be right back guys
all right i'm back all right i lied i wasn't getting water
don't be disappointed in me i say as you guys are going to
be disappointed in me i don't be disappointed in me but i
had to get something else as well and um i went to a caddy
store uh that was near the stadium well it wasn't near i had
about this while I was getting water and I was like, oh my
god, I bought this.
I bought a I bought a booboo rock candy.
It doesn't start with a chocolate booboo.
I got a la booboo rock candy.
I told you guys the picture of it.
It's a la booboo rock candy and it was so funny.
because, um...
It was so funny because there was a Swiss old couple.
I knew they were Swiss because they obviously had the Swiss
jerseys and stuff.
And...
And I was just like, La Pupu!
It's like while they were next to me because I was just
like, Oh, La Pupu Rock Candy!
I said it out loud, and I went and got one, and then the old
elderly thing is...
Oh, no, they got me.
They got me.
They're like, no, enough.
No more LaBoufou.
They silently, LaBoufou.
Got it.
There's no need to tell us why we'll be disappointed.
We are always disappointed.
Oh, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
I was confused why we would be disappointed by you, by
Candy.
Then you are answering.
And I showed the Canadian.
that they got talked it wasn't because of any people related
incident um it was because of the lapubu rock candy we'll
show it to you guys yes i need to show you guys my lapubu
rock candy let me let me let me let me send this picture to
myself my lapubu rock candy i just thought it was funny when
the only couple else like That's looking at it too.
He saw me looking at it and then to see a World Cup and buy
Laboobu in the same day.
No, that's not true.
I am not the last person because the elderly couple also
bought the Laboobu raw candy after I was like, Laboobu.
They also bought it.
They were even like, Laboobu.
So I wasn't the only one that bought it.
A nice Swiss elderly couple also bought the Booboo Rock
candy.
Me, why do you like this?
I thought it was funny.
Oh my god, it's cotton candy flavored.
I'm winning right now.
I'm...
I think I'm winning in life.
that's a curse artifact let me try and see if i can open it
all right i'm a bad influence on the i'm like the i'm like
the fucking telemarketer scammers hideous you're just a
hater because you're jealous you don't have your own cotton
candy flavored labooboo rock candy making people send your
retirement money.
It's a La Pupura candy.
And I'm gonna try it.
It's got a candy flavored, guys.
Alright.
I'm trying to open it, too.
Yes, I spent...
I don't even know how much I spent.
I literally just went swipe card.
Budge, thank you for the super chat.
thank you this is where my this is where my super chat bunny
goes also why the fuck do they put like paper in this box
when like with sticky candy like I feel like that's really
stupid oh it's good wait we can hear that ASMR
I'm rock candy ASMR Music's too loud Wait is the loud still
loud Wait is the music still loud guys Or is it just masking
the crunchy
Oh my god
Or it's not I can only bite it once It's so sugary It's rock
candy so it's all sugar It's oh yeah also another reason why
um the also another reason um why i bought the hospitality
ticket the vip ticket is that you get a little you get a
little souvenir too and it's a little it's a little fifa mug
um where you can put like it's one of those like okay let me
i'll just take a picture of it it's literally one of those
like little fifa mugs that they give you i didn't know what
the souvenir was because they don't tell you they're just
like you're gonna get a little to the um by coming to the by
buying this vip ticket so i was like oh sweet let's go all
right i mean show you is what it looks like it's pretty cool
yeah i got free mug i got free um i got a free little fifa
mug let me crop this oh let me send that and then save it
yeah it just has the fifa look it literally just has the
FIFA logo.
I was like, no, it's free.
Well, it wasn't free.
I paid, like, a lot of money for this ticket, but, you know,
free mug.
It's like, like, you know, free asterisks, you know?
Free mug.
Gotta spend, like, you know, a grand plus for this ticket,
but, ah, free mug.
Alright, where is it?
Here you go.
This was my free mug.
Yay, swag!
Free plus tournament conditions may apply.
Yeah.
It was VIP, though.
I will say, I think the benefit was it was that I would have
been in a giant-ass line, like, to get it.
Like, I, legit, like, there was, you know, several
entrances.
Oh, yeah, I'll let you guys look at the free mug that I got.
Free mug, with terms and conditions flat.
I know I said, I'm sorry I'm doing a lot of, like, going in
and out a lot, but I actually do want to pee.
I need to pee again.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Bathroom break over.
Okay, no more bathroom breaks for real now.
Oh, my gosh.
Rice, Ta, Min, Manny, Vince, Nexy, Smokey, uh, G.
Yes, yes, thank you, Mr. Pratchett, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, Mr.
Pratchett, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, I'm trying to
remember what else, what else I want to talk, what else did
I miss out on anything else, um, trying to see what else did
I miss out on I mean like it was a really fun experience
even though like um Canada lost the first time they've ever
lost on Vancouver soil by the way I was like it's me did I
is it because I went and bought a jersey and did I left my
seat was it me it was me wasn't it I should never left my
seat it was the dokey curse um but i still i i had a i had a
great time i think like like i said it was like uh it was
the first time i've ever watched like a world cup game in a
stadium in the stadium as well and it was just such a but at
least like you know at least like yeah at least i gave
mexico the buff though They gave the watch a lot of buff to
Mexico, though.
Literally started talking about Mexico and watching the
stream, and then they scored.
But it was a great experience.
I think also, I'm glad I know, I'm glad I bought the
hospitality ticket, because I did debate if I should get a
regular ticket or the hospitality ticket.
But I definitely, it was a lot better.
I think, like, I know you're like, oh, but you never
experienced the stadium.
But I was like, guys, those chairs were so comfy.
You know, like theater chairs?
That was the chair they gave us.
Like, it was a hard plastic.
There was cotton in my chair.
There was, yeah, yeah.
Guys, my chair had cotton.
cotton in it and like they gave there was a table too so
like basically like because the lounge is technically closed
during half time or like during the game but like if you're
in the mine's just a vip but if you're in the vvip or vvvip
um you can go to the lounge whenever you want i got her
again i don't know why i'm cutting in and out guys i'm sorry
I think it's a, I don't know, my internet is secure.
I think it's a YouTube thing.
I'm pretty sure it's a YouTube thing because, like, my
internet is stable right now.
But, yeah, like I said, the lounge is, like, inaccessible
when the game starts.
So you have to, like, basically what people did was that
they stock up on a bunch of drinks and food.
So they grab a bunch of food because the food is all you can
eat.
And also, like, a bunch of drinks because of alcohol.
and like water and like out like soft drinks everything was
all you can drink so everyone will just grab a bunch of
drinks and a bunch of food and just place it on the table
and then we just yeah and then and then you and then you
watch the game like on the table with a bunch of your food
and just chill like like i never had to let i never had to
leave i never had to get up grab food during half time like
line up or anything um i just like during i mean during half
time i went by jersey like that was the only thing i fucked
up on like but i got the photo with the trophy though i got
to i got to stand where i get to stand with like with all
the really really rich people we're at because i
accidentally i by accident i actually sneaked myself into
the lobby of the vv vip lobby and then like saw all the like
you know all the fucking multi-billionaires taking photos
with the trophy
And that lost Canada the game.
That's what did it, Doki.
And all those met Ryan, read us.
Why?
I'm pretty sure it's because they've already taken photos
with the trophy in the last...
In the Bosnia game, they didn't have to do it again.
Because they were like, we already did it.
So they didn't have to come out.
They didn't have to come out and take photos with it.
And then...
um what else um it was just i i will say if if you can if
you can afford it it it was a really good experience like
being in the the hospitality seat because okay the best part
about it no lines honestly that was like i did not realize
because like okay so i was really worried because when i
googled when i googled like when should i get there because
the hospitality thing opens for three hours and um and like
three hours before the game um and then like like so i was
just like oh should i get early to just get into the stadium
because i didn't realize like obviously i should have known
because like vip your vip you go in you have a i didn't
realize that i forgot they don't
by the way I don't mean it I was like oh they don't mix the
people together you know yes there's there's a separate
entries you know they don't you know it's it's segregated
like that's not it's a joke I'm trying to Trying to be, I'm
joking it.
I'm, you know, yeah.
So, I didn't realize that when I got the ticket.
Classes of Misery.
So, so, like, I, the segregation is real, guys.
So, I didn't realize that.
So, I got really worried because I was like, oh, shit.
early just to beat the lines because like um so so anyway I
woke up late it was really weird I was like what if they run
out of food because apparently the other stadiums were
really really bad for hospitality because people were
complaining about hospitality tickets in the other stadiums
like in the other in this in the I don't know if Toronto had
a similar issue but the ones in America hospitality was
really really bad experience for people because the food
kept running out like food kept running out and like drinks
weren't that like there wasn't not a lot of food and the
food wasn't running out of seats weren't that great so I got
really scared so I was like oh I need to get there two hours
early um or like I won't have good food like I won't be able
to like grab any food or like any of the drinks that they
run because apparently drinks ran out too in America So for
the hospitality tickets and So but when I got there There
was so much food still of like You know they kept refilling
it They kept and like it was really good Like they have a
cheese board guys And it wasn't like cheap ass cheese They
had like brie cheese and like a natural They had cheese like
you know like what you see at a fancy cheese board They have
like Canadian honey ham They had like katsu chicken Like
chicken waffas They had like all you can eat popcorn and
like all you can drink like every cost like all the
cocktails were still there And I was like 30 minutes before
the game starts like Like and they're like all and brownies
and desserts they had like ice cream they had like They had
chips tortilla that walk that guacamole and it was like
fresh guacamole and everything so it was just like so i was
like oh and i was 30 minutes before the game starts by when
i got there and so so i was like because i was reading the
reddit threads and like the forums talking about like
hospitality tickets so i was really worried that like
because they're like you need to get there two hours early
or like all the food's gonna run out and like there's gonna
be lots of lines and everything and I was like so scared
anyway I got there 30 minutes before the game started but it
was so nice it was like yeah it was and like and I was
worried about the lines because people were like being like
it wasn't worth it the hospitality ticket was not worth it
like oh what a waste of my money like there was no food like
the seats weren't even that great but my Actually, it was so
nice.
Like, like my chair was like comfy and I had a fucking
table.
Like, I mean, what more can I actually realize?
That's like not a lot of stuff.
And you think about it, like it's so basic.
Like, guys, my chair had cotton and I had a table.
I'm set.
Like, I realize I'm very low standards.
That's like three things.
yeah and a whole table and and anyway imagine having a whole
table wow and okay so i got really scared because i was like
oh am i gonna get into the stadium in time because it was
like 30 minutes before the game was about to start so i like
i didn't realize i was like was like I was following the
crowd and then I realized I was going the wrong way because
I was like this doesn't look like entrance one I'm at
entrance six now and then I asked like those the ladies with
the FIFA shirts and I was like do you know where entrance
one is I was just following the crowd and then she was like
oh you have to go back it's actually back there and then by
the way and then like so and then so back there and turn
right and then you'll find entrance one and then like to get
to entrance one there's like security guards and stuff and
like you're like you show your ticket because it was like
the vip section i was just following the crowd like the
signs just been like entrances to the right it doesn't tell
you where the hospitality entrance was so i was just
following the crowd because i was like well the sign says
right and the crowd's going there so anyway so when i got to
the entrance one area like the pre-security for entrance one
to even like set foot in the general vicinity of entrance
one there's where you have to show them the ticket.
Like, it's not even the scat part.
It's showing them because it's, like, fully blocked out.
And there's this tiny hole.
And they're like, please show us the ticket.
You can't go through this hole because that's where the
hospitality ticket holders were.
I went in.
And then there's, like, a little gap to the right of me
where you can sort of see the other entrance.
By the way, entrance one, no one was there.
It's like, everyone was already inside.
so I think like so I might have been the last person to go
in like with my in my like ticket area so um so I literally
just scanned scope went through I was the only one going
through security scanned and went straight to my hospital
like straight to my lounge but I had a glimpse of the other
entrance because there was a uh there was like a little area
where like it was a little like not that hole but like a
little corridor where you sort of see through the other
entrance and it was just all reds like all of the red shirts
and everything all crowded up lining up trying to get
through security and i was like oh my god 30 minutes before
the game i'm pretty sure i would have missed like at least
20 minutes game if i had to go through that entrance i i'm
pretty sure because they were still letting people in
they're still letting people into the stadium and it was 30
minutes before the game it was literally a sea of red red
shirts like it i just see like heads and red shirts for like
meters i won't say miles but i don't think i don't want to
like exaggerate but it was a lot of Like, like, it was, it
was a lot of people.
And I was just like, I was like, thank God.
Because I hate lines.
I really, really hate lines.
And I was like, oh my God, I'm so happy.
I, because I legitimately, it was just like, pop, pop, I'm
in.
Like, and I was just like, oh my God, there's so many people
there.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
They wouldn't have missed much.
Not gonna lie.
First head was, first half was fucking ass.
Nothing happened in the first half.
Like, it was legit first half.
Just Switzerland passing the ball for the 80th time.
And everyone in the stadium being like, boo.
Fucking, oh, there's a pass.
There's another pass.
Oh, another pass from Switzerland.
Who would have known?
Who would have fucking known?
So many passes.
Oh my God.
But like, I think like, if you ever have the opportunity, if
you're ever, okay, I don't, I think, I don't know about the
American stadiums.
The Canadian stadiums was so nice for the hospitality
tickets.
But I saw, but like, I literally saw zero reviews from
Canadian Redditors who bought hospice.
Like, I didn't see any reviews about hospitality tickets in
Canada.
italian tickets were about how fucking trash it was in
america so i was like did i fuck up like i was just like did
i fuck up should i just bought a normal ticket yeah yeah so
i'm glad like i took the gamba because i was just like i
thought about it for a while because there was like um like
i thought about it i was like oh my god do i get this ticket
and i was just like i do wanna i do wanna watch Because if
Canada loses, at least I'm comfortable, you know?
If Canada loses, at least I don't have to beat the crowds
to, like, go home.
Because you're allowed to stay in the lounge.
You're allowed to stay in the lounge, like, up to two hours
after the game ends.
So that's what I did.
Because I try to go, I try to leave after the game ended.
I went downstairs.
And then, like, wait, I took a picture of it.
Saw this and then I went back into the lounge
I saw it I went back to the lounge Cause I was like that's
too many people I don't want to deal with that man That's
too many Let me make my money I just stayed there and just
ate more food Like it was just too many I don't feel well
like crowds Like, I just literally just sat there and waited
until, uh, I waited until, like, I waited like an hour
before I left.
It was just too many people.
I just, I felt like I would have been so, I'm not
claustrophobic.
I felt like I had claustrophobia.
Just like, like, I saw this.
And that was me waiting like 10 minutes, too.
So, I saw this.
Like, and then I was just like, I'm just going to go back to
the lounge and wait an hour before I go.
Oh, yeah.
It's just way too many people.
Yeah.
Looking, thank you.
Why are you looking?
That's not on purpose.
That's not on purpose, guys.
Yeah.
That's it was a lot of people.
I'm the one that like squish in between a bunch of people
when I want to go home I Like
How dare you look at the masses turkey Yeah, so that was
like so I just went back to the lounge and just hanged like
just Hanged out in the lounge and just ate more free food
and free drinks.
Lexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And like, because like, also, because like, it was downtown,
right?
It was downtown.
So there was, like, a lot of people.
I, like, walked 14 minutes down until, like, I stopped
seeing red shirts.
And then went into a restaurant because every other place
was just fully packed with, uh, with like lot like you know
with everyone trying to get food and hanging out drinks and
watching the other shows on tv i just walked down the road
for like 15 like 15 minutes until i like got to one uh got
to a restaurant that like that like was not like fully
booked and crowded like legitimately just like the red
shirts just stopped like like there was no more like there
were people You know, I was just like, oh my god, like, like
I saw people actually wearing different colored shirts I was
like, oh my god, I made it.
I I made it these people don't know soccer.
I They're like they're they're just tourists or they're just
they're just tourists or they're just like hanging out like
I there is one thing I regret is that I didn't realize that
there was a area for free swag I did not realize that there
is a there's an apparently there was like a pavilion or some
shit or like a sanctioned off area where you can get free
swag from like all the sponsors or like I don't know But I
saw someone in chat being like, oh, she could have got a
Coca-Cola cape.
And I was just like, there was a free swag.
I could have got a Coca-Cola cape.
I don't care what it was.
It was free.
As long as it's free.
So I didn't realize because I was like, I don't know.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But you have to.
Okay, the one other thing that's so fucking stupid is that
when you get a ticket, to like download the app to see the
ticket um and like you can't see it on your emails or
anything um and literally you have to download an app to see
your ticket and then there's like another app to see like
how to get there and everything like you that's the only way
to access your fucking ticket to the world cup uh yeah it's
all digital now but you have to download their app because
they want your information on your phone uh you know as if
like the world company needs more information about me uh
yeah so like they just want you know they just want more
information so they can grab it from your phone um and uh
and like if you ever seen the fifa map it's not very helpful
because you're like there's like a bunch of shit like oh
there's this stuff doesn't tell you exactly what they are
because there was one where it's like the FIFA fan
experience or whatever or the FIFA pavilion I'm like what
the fuck does that mean and I try to Google it but they just
it doesn't tell you anything and I was just like I don't
know what that means like I don't know do I want to go there
I don't know what it does like and I was like um I'm tired I
just I don't
I'm going home.
It's a long drive home.
So I might as well go home now.
I literally had to make my waiting room tweet.
Like I couldn't do my usual template because I was in the
car.
And I was just like, I'm just going to do like be like, Hey,
I'm going to, I'm in the car right now.
But day stream at seven.
So I didn't realize that there was free swag that missed out
on.
Oh my god.
I don't care if it's, I don't care what it was.
It was free.
I might as well go there.
Oh yeah.
Also, apparently, uh, people are scalping this like little,
um, lanyard that they gave us, um, gave like everybody where
it's like, I don't know.
When I was at the restaurant, the server was like, oh,
they're scalping these for $30.
And I was like, damn, they're like, you should keep it
because like a bunch of people are scalping these on ebay
now um so it's like it's just a little card thing it's
called the fifa fan fan experience id and i was just like
what the fuck is this and then like i don't know i was just
like free is free you know i didn't use it or anything but
it was basically like if you take photos of your time at the
fifa stuff you can make merch out of it and like uh get like
dirt hoodie you can you can buy merch off based off of the
you take at the beef like at the world cup stadium and um
and i'll just and they're like oh you can make 30 dollars i
was like 30 i'm just i'm gonna say it that with the amount i
paid for that ticket why fuck like 30 i'm just saying like
when the amount i paid for it the ticket itself to like be
there like i was like that 30 dollars compared to the full
amount i paid to like be watching at the stadium and i
better keep it as a memorabilia at that point yeah 30 is 30
so dokey like um i did not buy scalp tickets for those who
are wondering but even then it was very i did buy the
hospitality ticket but it wasn't a cheapest hospitality
ticket it was the second uh it was the second cheapest
hospitality ticket because that was the only one that was
left um but even then it was very expensive and if you try
to buy my ticket scoped the prices for it tripled um to what
it was i will i think it was like
last i think i checked on the ticket price like the two days
two days before uh it was three dollars canadian if we if i
scalped a little fucking stupid ass id card and i was like
i'm not gonna fucking scalp that like what the fuck like
it's like 30 dollars compared to what i had fucking paid for
like to be there um but i will say how much it ended up
getting scalped two days before two days before the game.
I don't know what it was last day, but two days before the
game, I saw that it went up to $9,000 for one ticket.
That's how far, that's like for the same ticket as, I saw it
went up to $9,000 and mine was not 9K.
Yeah, and I was just like, Jesus Christ.
I don't remember if it was Canadian or USD, because I was
looking at stub hub yeah and you know what was crazy I saw
some of the scalp resale tickets on the FIFA website that
were like around the same price as my hospitality ticket but
like it doesn't include hospitality it was just like the
middle seats it was like below like the front like not it
wasn't even front it was like middle row in the middle
section and it was around like and it was around the same
price as my hospitality ticket that I bought but like
without from without reselling because they had because I
bought it the day before Qatar before Canada be Qatar so
there were so many hospitality tickets like hospitality is
the VIP so there was like there were so many and I was just
like looking at the resale tickets on the I was just like
Well, this is without the VIP, but it's like in the middle
section.
So I was like debating about, do I get the middle section or
do I get the hospitality, the VIP ticket?
Because like the VIP ticket is in the corner.
You can see where I was sitting on the, I was sitting on
like, you know, as I sit on Swiss side, it was either Swiss
going to be there or Canada went half time.
So that's why I was just like thinking, I've thought for a
long time.
And then I was just like, fuck it.
I'm gonna I'm gonna buy it because when will I ever
experience it yet not knowing because I was like I'm busy
during Canada because I was like do I buy Canada versus
Qatar or Canada versus Switzerland and I was like oh I'm
busy during Canada versus Qatar because I didn't go in
thinking like you know I was like oh I'm just gonna watch
Canada get his ass kicked I might as well watch it while in
comfort because you know we never won a we never qualified
in FIFA we never won a game before so then the day before
the Qatar game I bought the ticket because I was like I
can't make it to I'm busy that week, but I can make it to
the Switzerland game because I can find I can find time on
that day to do it I don't have any obligations, and then
it's like investing in Google, you know, like
Yeah, I was just it felt like I was investing in Google and
then the day after can the fucking score six goals and I was
just like what the
It's like stunks
the return of investment yeah that's crazy
I know I could have been in that Canada versus Qatar game I
legitimately was busy on that day I don't remember what I
was doing but I know that day was fully booked up like um
anyway so I don't even know how I got to that topic oh yeah
but yeah like I said like um i felt like it was worth it the
um i felt it was it was definitely worth it to get by the
vip tickets like i said i thought about it for a while being
like why get it do i not get it i'm glad that i gambled
because even though i read bad reviews about it for the
american stadiums luckily the canadian stadiums were It was
really nice.
I've never been to that Canadian.
I've never been to the Canadian stadium before.
Like the, what's it called, BC Place.
I've never been to BC Place before.
So, like I said, I've never really watched sport events in a
stadium before.
Never really.
I said I've never watched sport events in a stadium before.
So, it was a great experience.
It was really intense.
It was very, very intense watching it live, like, in person.
Because, you know, you're, like, whatever happens in there
is from the feedback of the other fans as well.
So you get, like, the hype-ness of, like, everyone around
you as well.
So, like, everyone around you, you get, like, super hyped
and stuff, too.
So it's like, whoa, whoa!
And then everyone stands up as the goal gets, like, as the
ball gets closer to watch the shots and being, like, whoa!
boo yeah so it was it was a really really cool experience um
and um i'm glad i get to experience like i'm glad i get to
be a part of it too um yeah the energy of the stadium is
really cool and it was it was it was a really fun
opportunity to do it i don't know about do it again um but i
enjoyed watching that game even though we didn't win it was
still a very hyped game uh but like look it passed so fast i
didn't realize 90 minutes went by so fucking fast uh i like
i legit like looked on my phone and was like what the fuck
like i was like that much time has already passed what did
like happen um but yeah anyway like i said for those who are
new in chat right now this was my favorite moment I didn't I
saw it live but like I didn't understand what's going on but
I saw it on gift form and I was like oh that's why both
players got yellow cards like
it's so fast too it happens really really fast too it's so
far I have to this fucking fucking funny because why did he
kick the ball why did he do that he didn't have to kick it
it's so funny um all right another change of topic dokey
dokey rewind time has officially sold out Yay!
Thank you, everyone, for the insane support.
All right, let me...
Let me grab the visuals real quick, guys.
I have the graphics here.
Let me see.
Oh, where is it?
I'll send the graphic.
Give me a sec.
All right.
all right i'll send some stuff so i'm gonna show you guys
some behind the scenes too of the doki dokiy rewind time i'm
doing this live by the way so i have to let's see let me
grab this real quick all right sorry guys i'm doing this
live So, like I said, I got home and then, like, I got sent
all of these things.
So, I'm just, I'm just fucking pulling it all up right now.
Uh, okay, where is it?
Where did I save the graphic?
What the fuck?
Where did I save it?
What is it called?
Oh, it's because it's JPEG large.
There we go.
Where is this?
By, all right, there we go.
Reset.
Yeah!
Thank you, everyone!
With insane support.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you know it's called soccer because they wear socks when
they play?
What is it called soccer?
I actually don't know.
Well, think about the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When will the merch details be released?
I think soon slash TM.
They're just getting some final samples for some of the
merch.
And I asked if I could add bundles to it.
I don't know, there'd be freebies here, but I did ask if
they could add bundles for the merch, so that would be
cheaper.
You want to grab everything.
So they're working on that right now, because I obviously,
you know, I want to make sure.
And I asked them to lower the prices for some of the items,
because I thought it was some of them were just way too
expensive.
I did not feel comfortable.
Like, I know, like, you know, it's like profit, profit, but
like, I want it to, like, it's not like, I still want it to
be, like, sort of affordable.
were the prices for some of the items that was being sold so
obviously that delayed that delayed the merch stuff a bit as
well because i was just like like i was like you know i was
like i don't feel comfortable upselling like i don't know
not upselling but you know what i mean i was like i'd rather
make less money like because i still want it to be
affordable so like i i was like i don't mind taking the hit
like i don't i don't mind like you know having like profit
like bigger profit margins or whatever i'd rather like have
something fun for you guys to have like i'm not like not
making money in terms like i'm not making any profit but i
still like i you know when i see something i was like that
is way too expensive like please lower it like so um and
they were very accommodating with that they were super
accommodating and was like and they because i asked for like
certain items to be lowered because i was just like oh i
don't want to ask too much but then they lowered the prices
for all the items in there so it's not like a huge lowered
but you know it's like they took like five to ten dollars
off which made me a lot more comfortable um and i was like
yeah it's fine because you know like and then they gave us
like a breakdown of everything too like oh like uh this is
how much it costs to produce and then this is like this is
how much it costs to produce and this is like uh how much
you'll make off of it with the newer price breakdown and
everything i was like i was fine with that and so that's why
it delayed a bit and that's that's like my bad but i wanted
to try and make it like i didn't you know I was just like I
didn't feel comfortable so um so I'm really appreciative of
the fact that like they lowered lowered it for me um like
and I like spoke up about it being like oh and then we're
trying to see if we can do bundles so it'll lower the cost
even more for those who want to buy everything um so we'll
we'll see how it goes so um my manager is working on that
right now um what else don't want to talk oh yeah i was
gonna pin it but if you if you still want to watch the
concert we have streaming tickets out yeah all right let me
uh let me see i can grab the link to it real quick uh but
for those who still want to watch uh if you look at the top
right corner you can change the language to english so it
because it is a Japanese website and I saw people being like
it's so hard to navigate it will just Google Translate so if
you look at the top right corner you can change the language
to English so it'll be easier to fill it in streaming
tickets where the concert is out now alright I need to make
a tweet about that too but yes thank you guys so much for
the insane amount of support for the concert.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thanks for doing this, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So I really, really appreciate you guys for helping me sell
on this concert.
I was really, really fucking worried because like I said, I
know I'm not like well known as a singer as a YouTuber.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
you are allowed to share gifts and photos of the concert on
social media and stuff you're allowed to to like live tweet
about it uh share gifts uh share uh uh pictures and
everything and so do not have to worry about that you want
to live tweet you want to talk about it live or anything
that is fine as long as there's no videos or anything that
new outfit design looks cute.
I hope we get to see more of it.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I will be showing behind the scenes stuff too.
So, this is the reference.
For it.
Bound.
Here you go.
I want you guys to know it was really, really hard.
What I was a little bit of a diva.
I might have been a bit of a diva when it came to this, to
the key visual, because I did not like the first draft.
I was not a huge fan of the very first draft.
By the way, this outfit will be used for the merch and the
key visual.
Chibi looked amazed.
I loved Chibi's outfit.
Here's the design.
Nope, nothing was changed.
But I'll show you guys the very first design, the very first
draft.
I didn't like it because I felt like it didn't feel like me.
And it felt like, by the way, this is not the new 3D outfit.
By the way.
So, it's a different outfit.
But it's also around a similar theme.
So, for the concert, it's an even different outfit.
It's another new outfit, too.
so um anyway uh i love the end result of this because when
we started i was not like a huge fan of the design i wasn't
a fan like i just didn't like it at all in general because i
just felt like i just felt like it just there it was just i
don't know it just didn't feel like me it just didn't feel
like me and also like there's stuff that like there was like
lots of piercings on my face too and i'm not a piercing type
of gal and also i don't really like i'm so sorry i did i
like personally wise this is my personal fashion sense i'm
not a fan of piercings on the face and stuff too so it like
that's just me i didn't want to have piercings on my face
just because i personally won't have it like i know it would
fit the theme but like for me personally i just i don't have
piercings on my face um and like i personally just don't
like that style so i got asked them to remove it and stuff
um also fudge thank you for super chat thank you thank you
um the key visual is so good you never miss her kv outfits
chibi looks like your sibling or a pet thank you super chat
thank you thank you anyway so for originally my outfit was a
different color so and i had the biggest struggle when it
came to my outfit colors like we had a poll vote and
everything so um so we we gathered the mods and the staff to
have a big poll vote because i was so conflicted about the
colors because before because this is the punk this is like
punk punkish colors that we settled on but before it would
have been purple It would have been Urple because that fit
the emo vibe the emo Gothi vibe more because we wanted to
touch in on the whole emo gothic punk vibe Well, you know
the super chat that you think is six foot versus five foot
eleven, but we decided To it was so hard because I was I was
trying to fight for team purple Because individual wise
individually was, um, I thought, like, if you just look at
me, and I'm purple, like, with the purple outfit, it, like,
looked so good.
But then when it was next to Cheepy, it felt like I was
blending in too much with Cheepy.
So, like, like, that was the whole thing, because if we're
in the key visual, in the key visual, it was me and Cheepy,
it just, it was, like, too much purple.
So, problem that's why I was just like I needed the contrast
because like it just didn't work but like if I look at
myself individually it looked really good so I was so
conflicted yeah I was so fucking conflicted but but but that
doesn't mean uh let me know I voted for herbal yeah yeah but
But that doesn't mean that Erpo design got scrapped because
if you are a VIP holder, if you bought a VIP ticket, you
will get the alternative color design of the postcard where
it's Erpo in the key visual.
You will get the key visual postcard where I'm wearing the
purple outfit and that's purple variant of the of of the
design so so that's like the exclusive bonus for the vip
ticket holders so the all the other stuff all the regular
merch is gonna be the the red variant but like urpal is like
the the shiny pokemon you know yeah it's the shiny so you
guys get the so the vip ticket holders will get the urpal
edition of the new of the key visual elephant it's like
fortnite all over again ramona thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you god damn those outfits are amazing also
even though it's a two-day shot my birthday past my birthday
we get belated happy of course of course i'll give you a
belated happy birthday to you uh ramona uh thank you again
for the akasupa thank you thank you happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy Dear Ramona, happy birthday to
you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy belated birthday.
We had a good one.
Nia, give me the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Next seat, they give me the super chat.
Now that's a VIP perk.
Thank you, Doki.
I'm so excited.
Nia, the super chat.
Nia, thank you.
Papa, Nia, Nia, Nia, Nia, super chat.
Thank you.
SSR, Doki, let's fucking go.
Nia, super chat.
Nia, thank you.
Thank you.
all right let me show you the draft designs i don't know
that do i have it saved it will have the first design saved
let me check guys i'm gonna have to go through the group
chat again um let me see if i don't then i have to i might
not i don't think i do let me double check no let me okay i
gotta find the group chat for this It's been a while.
It's sort of been a while.
All right, let me find it.
Uh...
All right, here we go.
All right, this...
No, was this the original theme?
I'm just gonna save this real quick.
All right,
I'm saving all the designs real quick.
to see if i can
uh there were so many i'm so i was i was a diva for this i
was like i don't know i was such a perfectionist um when it
came to trying to make the perfect outfit because like i
really really wanted to fit the theme well and like i wanted
to i just wanted to fit the theme really I wanted to have
like it matching the fashion and the style of what we're
going for for this concert And it was like so hard.
It was so hard to nail it down So I was like really happy
with the final result because like just to get there was a
journey and I really appreciate the artist Like because I
felt so bad because the artist was like, oh our deadline's
getting closer And I was like, oh, but I needed to be
perfect.
I'm sorry So I was like I was like so like specific about
everything Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We'll be posting a reference on Twitter after the concert.
I may post a reference late before the concert.
I'm just, you know, I have a lot of other stuff going on.
So it's just me being bad with social media right now.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like the VIP people get the Pokemon shiny version, the
merch.
I'm so happy I spent.
Oh my God, Medi.
Make sure you have enough Medi for food.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
all right oh my god guys there's so many traps guys i didn't
realize how long this process was this was a very long
process everybody all right give me a sec it took us a while
to get there it really did
oh yeah by the way the key visual originally didn't have you
guys in it but I requested to have you guys in it um I was
just like you know I want you guys to be part of like as
much as much as possible so originally you guys weren't in
the key visual so I was like can you guys add the drag
wounds in there um and also it was my idea to make like do
the uh like like an MTV parody on the screen because
originally it was like it was like a screen with like
miniature versions of me and Shibi but I felt like it was
just too much it was too much like character art on there so
I was like could you change it to like yeah DTV and I sent
in like references and stuff to like MTV logo so I really
like that little touch that we did so I'm glad like it
turned a lot better versus like the little visuals of us in
there Just like the small, like, you know, the little small
things that changed that helped a lot with the overall
visual.
All right, let me see.
I'm scrolling up.
Trying to find more.
I'm just trying to make sure that I got everything.
I'm scrolling.
I think this was it.
okay yeah it was this all right so this was the very first
one that was sent oh my god all right so uh this design i'm
just gonna show mine and not cheap should she be it was like
done they said her design and like i loved it too i was just
like oh my god that's like perfect actually so pretty and
then uh like and then mine was like there were so many uh
concepts i'm sorry so this was the original this was the
original and i'm sorry if everyone's like no that one's so
good i did not fuck with that this design i was not a huge
fan of this design um because of I said, I wasn't, it was
very, it was very edgy, you know, like, it was like, um, it
was like, super edgy, and it was more emo vibes, but like, I
didn't want it to be, like, super emo, you know, um, and so,
like, because I wanted the fashion to be, like, a mixture of
every, thing and not just like emo you know so like it had
the emo tropes with like the you know the the god like the
shirt yeah like seen very scene like um so and then you know
like with the piercings everywhere and all of that and
everything so i wasn't like a huge fan i wanted like a
little bit of i i wanted a mixture of different fashions
related to the uh so for those don't this was the final i'll
show you guys the final to compare uh to compare it to
compare the two together so this was the one that we ended
up on and this was the first design so you can tell like i i
changed a lot at the top part um at first we tried a
different things at the bottom as well but it didn't work
out so i was just like i think the pants was the was good
like i think we can keep the pants and i wanted more
different like i wanted more uh i wanted more like uh
mixture of different fashions from goth from emo from punk
not just full emo because also there we don't have a lot of
emo sounds we have like like you know like maybe two songs
that are emo in the set list so i didn't want to hyper focus
on emo and uh so i didn't want to like be like oh it's a
full emo concert you know like so so i still wanted to like
like it's like a culmination of all the all the styles
together to like be like this is like a nostalgic concert
I wasn't like a huge fan of the like I said of the top part
of this in general and then alright so let me show you the
process getting there because it was a long process I feel
so bad so anyway now this is the red version of it and then
they're like what if we make it the colors more punkish so I
kept some of the colors and
and you know like i i was thinking about it because like
punk is more about like for those who don't know punk is
more like lots of bright colors in punk too so um and it was
a better contrast with chibi so i thought about the color
designs as well for those who were wondering like why didn't
keep the eyes you know like the like i said i didn't really
like the the clips as well i felt like you know if you're
looking at because I was like okay we'll keep the emo hair
you know like the emo hair for that we'll keep that from the
original concept but I didn't want the clips or anything
because I felt like it was too much it was too and you don't
really see that in like emo hair and everything so I was
just like I asked to get rid of it and and because I felt
like you know when your, you know, the classic emo hair,
like, it felt like a bit too much, because it didn't feel
like the style itself.
And as well as the, like, the little weeping eyeshadow, I
asked for eyeliner, I don't even notice that, but instead
of, like, the, the weeping eyeshadow, uh, I asked for the,
the eyeliner instead, um, instead of that.
So that's, like, the little changes I made, because I did
want to keep a more cleaner face to fit the style versus
like adding more, versus the scene part.
Alright, this is where it gets funky.
We were like, let's just experiment.
Let's just go fucking wild.
So, so, this is when we started going a little funky with
it, because I was still deciding what to do.
So, what happened?
So, um, this is where we started getting a little weird with
it.
Because I wanted to with some stuff um and so this is more
skate punk now now we're at skate punk category like
category and i did like the pants i did like the pants but i
felt like might be a little similar to another outfit so the
other thing that i wanted to avoid was that to make the key
visual different from pretend from another outfit so I
wanted it to be a different fashion so it'd be a more of a
surprise on what the other outfit could look like
so so I'd like the pants for this I was like oh I do like
this like the because it does feel very so so i had to pivot
away from that because i still i didn't want it to look
similar to like i don't want a similar fashion style for the
other outfit the other 3d outfit so that's how we got to our
end result because it was a different it was a different
style but i did like the bracelets and everything because
that's what because that's what the fashion was like back
then for those who didn't know where there was like a ton of
bracelets and everything on the arm um because then like
people back then would wear like a ton of bracelets and
stuff um and like like wristbands and everything so so uh i
tried to keep that i kept that part in there because i
wanted to keep up with the the fashion sense back in the day
anyway so then we started getting a little bit more funky
and we added like something like this too well and like i
said we were like going through lots of different ideas so
and then this is where it gets super funky now we're now
we're like experimenting a lot there was a lot of
experimentations going on so we're like okay what if we make
it into shorts what if we do shorts i have no complaints
right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you but i
didn't really with that one yeah it was like weird because
there wasn't really leg warmers back in the day too like
people don't really uh wear like warmers back then uh so uh
so we were like uh no i didn't i i felt like yeah it didn't
feel 90s early 2000s so we scrapped that idea uh and um i
don't know if i wanted shorts i was just like i don't know
it it it doesn't really, it's just, I don't know there was
just something off of us.
And then we were talking, we look at different colors too.
So there was like, like I don't know why.
And then green showed up.
I don't know.
Green.
I was just like, can we try different color combos too?
Because I don't know.
I'm having trouble with the colors.
So I don't know.
Green is, green showed up.
Green, yeah.
We're throwing colors at the wall.
See what ever sticks.
Yeah.
I don't know, green got invited somehow.
And then I was just like, okay, what if we take off the
shirt?
Why don't we take off the shirt and see what that looks
like?
Like, just have a tank top.
And I was like, that's too plain, you know?
That's just way too plain.
The tank top was just, I don't know.
It just didn't feel like, it didn't really feel like, you
know, it's just too simple.
It's way too simple.
like, okay, we'll put a star on it.
What if we just put a star on it?
And I still didn't really fuck with it.
Because I was like, it just felt like a tank top.
And then I was like, all right.
But what if, give her a jack, what if we go back to like,
you know, like a, I guess, I don't know, like a tank top
bra.
I don't remember what it's called.
Like a, and give her a jackie.
because like that didn't really like the back design of the
jacket and i looked it just looked too what's it called
what's that word called uh we're like what's no i'm like it
looked you're halfway to a sloppy sister's punk ensemble
here right thank you it looked too cheuny.
That's what I'm trying to say.
It looked really cheuny.
And I'm like, I don't know.
It feels a little...
Yeah, I was just like...
It just feels a little too cheuny.
You know?
Like...
Yeah.
It started to crop top.
That's what I was trying to say.
And then, so we scrapped the jacket idea.
And then... And then Bob's like, take off the jacket
instead.
And then we go back to the punk colors and then but we keep
all the other stuff we just got to take the jacket off and
then go with the red instead of the purple and that's and
then put the bracelets back and that's where we ended up on
in the end and also necklace because I realized like like
back in the day everybody assessorized and that's how we got
there that's how we got to the the final the final result of
the key visual yeah and now you get to see the shoulders too
yeah that's what i'm saying i was like so from the first
design all right the very first design
all the way to the last design so left is the very first
design we got and then right was the final design and like
that was the whole journey that we to get there and i like i
said like it would i was a little bit of a deep i asked for
so many changes because i really wanted something that that
was perfect for the key visual and i loved how it turned out
in the end because i Like, the first design could have been
fine, but I didn't want it to be fully emo.
That was my biggest problem.
Like, if I was doing an emo concert, then, like, it makes
sense, but I wasn't doing an emo concert.
I was doing, like, a mixture of different genres and
everything.
So I wanted that to be, like, something like that as well.
Like, just a mixture of different fashions.
And it didn't feel like me in a way.
way so um i'm i'm happy with the final design uh even though
it took a lot yes like i said chibi was one and done like
perfect like chibi perfect it's one and done no changes
whatsoever like like she got it right off the bat me i had a
whole fucking journey uh to get there But I really
appreciate the artist putting up with me for it.
Oh yeah, here's the sketch for it.
Like I said.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I had to eliminate a couple of dragoons.
Because I felt like it was too much.
But this was the line art.
So it used to be a lot different.
As you can see.
The key visual used to be a lot different.
And I was like, remove that dragoon.
Remove that one.
Remove that.
Because I was just like, look.
Like it was just because like.
It felt like.
It, we, it, like some drag, like, you know, like, I need to
fit more of the theme, too.
Um, and I just wanted one of each dragon there, so, like,
one of each type.
So, you know, there's like different, there was too many,
I'm sorry, there was too many dragons.
Like, so, so I wanted, like, one of each type around, but
also not, like, it was like, you know i'm trying you know i
didn't want one type of dragoon to have more exposure versus
the other we're all equal here like everyone is portrayed
equally on this artwork and like yeah i see originally
instead of dtv it was like a like it was just another
picture of us too i felt like it was too much so i asked
them that they could change the dtv and also i removed the
stickers and stuff because i also felt like it was too much
it didn't fit the vibe and everything so i asked and like
make it just a regular tv um and yeah it looked i mean i was
like the original lineup for it before i got my hands on it
um but that was the whole behind the scenes um um of this
journey that i had with the key visuals but yes you can get
the streaming tickets right now uh to watch it
of the event for those who can't make it to la uh i mean the
concert is sold out right now so like even you made it to la
i'm sorry like we won't be able to win i'm so sorry uh yes
merch will be sold online so do not worry about that there
will be merch sold online and uh and also thank you for the
raid i really appreciate we had a good stream thank you um
and what else What is that I want to say?
Oh,
yes.
And there will be a streaming preview.
So, during the, when the concert goes live, there will be a
stream preview of the concert of the first three songs.
And Mimi's, my duet with Mimi will be part of the free
preview.
So, after the three songs are over, it'll just cut to, like,
you know, like, I don't know, maybe.
be like a visual to be like here's where you can buy tickets
for the rest of the concert but you can use the the stream
to like chat about the concert if you guys want to so that's
why we're keeping it up so you can chat in the little so you
have your own little chat room to live chat about the the
concert with other dragons as well so there will be a stream
preview um there will be a stream preview for um for
everybody uh for free uh first three three songs of the Will
be available for all of you guys.
For those who can't afford the concert.
Can't afford the streaming tickets.
You still will be able to have a chance to experience the
concert.
So yeah, that should be everything, I think.
I think I got everything.
But it's been a long day.
It really has been.
I may have made a little oopsie and got like four hours of
sleep today.
I mean, I did nap.
I took a little nap.
I took a little nap on the car.
home and also a little nap when I got home.
But I was practicing, okay?
I was practicing for the tournament that I can't say what it
is yet.
Okay, guys, I was practicing for the tournament that I
cannot mention.
Like I had to.
I needed to practice, guys.
For the tournament that I can't mention yet.
you might have seen me on other people's streams um oh my
god i will okay this doesn't all right so this doesn't leak
what the turn this may or may not leak what the tournament
is but i got it i got on a team with a pro player that was
smurfing with uh and playing um with his uh girlfriend and
then girlfriend didn't like me because and she sort of
blamed the game loss on me um and then uh and then I was
like hey isn't that player on our team smurfing I think it's
this player so I looked up the stream of the player and then
I think I saw them avoid me and then they lost me three
times in a row And then I was like, karma.
I didn't say anything, though.
But in my heart, I was like, karma.
I just thought it was funny.
I did not say anything.
I didn't do anything.
They avoided me.
This wasn't...
This happened yesterday.
This literally happened yesterday, guys.
You're like, I remember this story.
Did this happen before?
Well, it happened again.
I just thought it was...
Because I just thought it was really funny.
Like, maybe I had the better team.
But I'm like, bro, that's...
That pro player was not at all to...
That pro player was smurfing!
Like...
The bad... Like... The bad...
They had all... They had enough advantages.
I feel like...
No, they were on my team first.
Like when I first bumped into them.
They were on my team.
And then... Uh... It was just...
We... Just... Me and Her just had no chemistry.
In the game.
I guess.
weird like i i'm trying to say it in like as little terms as
possible to not reveal what the turn game is for this
tournament so i was practice like i said i was practicing
and then and then like they got mad at me because i did
stuff like it was like just it was it was a final play where
i did something that um that didn't throw the entire game
but you know it was a mistake And I own up to it.
And then, but then it was like all the blame was sort of put
on me.
Even though I was like, there's no way.
I had my stats.
I tried not to, my stats in the end was better than her.
So I was just like, I didn't avoid her.
I didn't avoid her.
But like, and then I found out she avoided.
me uh so so and then so because i looked at the stream and
then and then i got against them three times in a row and
then and they lost three times in a row against me i say
anything karma
I just played the game.
That's all I'll say.
I guess I'm gonna...
Yeah, so, so like, that was yesterday.
Yeah, I wish...
Okay, okay, this is so...
It's so fucked up, but like, it was also a little...
funny because I got it like um when I won in that game I
won't show the chat logs but it was so funny it was so I
felt bad but also like oh my god that's so funny but because
it was just like that's so awkward for the streamer but for
the first game I won against them I'm so pity I'm sorry It
was just, I just thought it was so funny.
So, the very first game, I won against them right after they
avoided me.
Some, one of their team members went into the guy's stream
and was like, GG's, it's not your fault.
This player was just so bad on our team.
And then, and then later on, he wrote another message and
was like, Oh, you're dueled with her.
Um, good luck in your next game.
Super fun.
This is so.
I was like, no, I was like,
I'm not great.
I know.
The stupid way, bro.
Actually, same.
the chat logs because that was so funny
it was like the guy was so ignorant he didn't he was like
it's not bro ggs man it's not you this player was just so
bad and then he's like oh you're too good luck next game
sorry i'm alive I'm sorry it was just so funny just like I'm
rereading the chat looking the chat logs again oh my god I'm
sorry it was so funny because it was so easily avoidable you
know like if you waited a second to see the dual screen like
to see the menu if he waited one more second before
submitting it
so i'm just like oh my god what do you even do with that you
just bat him he didn't bat him though i didn't see what he i
didn't see what he said when he noticed it i was just
looking at the chat looking at the chat box and i was just
like oh my god i wish i knew what he's i just i would just i
don't know i would just ban that guy i'd be like bro i would
i would have banned that guy like i you know if i was in his
shoes i would have banned him because i i don't want my
girlfriend see that bro she's gonna feel like shit bro what
the fuck as a boy as a good boyfriend you should have
deleted that message man bro you want her to see that like
yeah i would have deleted that bro oh my god anyway it
wasn't deleted because i checked back the vibe and it was
still there.
The chat log was still there because I was just like, bro,
what the fuck?
Why is it still up there?
Oh my God.
Um, but yeah, anyway, that was my day yesterday.
So yeah, that's why I didn't sleep that much.
I was practicing for the tournament that I can't mention yet
because I can, I can only mention it when they announced it
because that's why nobody's talking about this tournament
yet because we're not allowed to until it's publicly
announced.
most likely I'll be announced tomorrow.
Most likely.
Because then it'll be the date before the tournament.
It has to be.
But yeah.
But it isn't really the streamers for hot oh thank you thank
you um oh yeah anyway it's time to i know i guess we can
game now like i all right all right i'm wait where is it i
wanted to play this game i know like i said i was gonna play
it i really wanted to play this game on stream i tried it a
little bit um I tried it a little bit Offstream.
It's really fun But I think it's gonna die In like a week I
don't think this game has a long shelf life So for those who
don't know Impulse is made by the same people Who made
Splitgate And it's a fun Aiming game But I feel like this
game would 100% die in within maybe a month or so.
And I do not like the Mecca stuff.
I do not like that.
I just like shooting things.
Also, it feels very like there is like control.
There is aim assist, apparently.
Because I was getting absolutely destroyed.
by controller players um okay this is my feedback i know i'm
giving a lot eight the shooting the gun fun very fun to
shoot the gun very fun mechanic very fun movement very it's
play to win it is 100 play to win what do i mean by that to
unlock cooler weapons you have to play longer and the longer
you play you get more perks and more upgrades and perks for
the gun you like and everything play to win because you know
all the strongest guns the strongest perks are locked behind
playing longer so uh so that's like the issue with this game
um and um it takes a while to upgrade stuff it's better than
pay to win but it's like yeah uh so there's like uh so
you're not if someone has if someone I'm talking about
impulse so I'll be playing impulse right now because I
wanted to play a little bit because impulse just released
today I thought about it I was like do I play impulse uh
today or do I play next week and I worry if I wait next week
all the players on impulse are going to be like roided up so
so I was just like I'll play it now when I'm against players
who are still sort of new at the game yeah it's it's not
very i will say like um it's not beginner friendly at some
point when when the sbmm hits it hits hard and i really did
not there are some game modes that i'm not a huge fan of
like i really hated some game like uh i really hated some of
the stuff um let's see huh let me grab some things right now
I don't I don't know something useful today kid all right
where is it is it called Orion no death or violence is that
what it is oh it is why is it called Orion All right, how's
the sound right now?
They couldn't fix themselves.
And it worked.
But it kept- Play longer to unlock better- better gear was
9% 9% progression worked before the invention of the battle
pass score.
And then you have a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm used to everything just being available.
Because I play like, you know, I play hero shooters and
battle royale.
I'm not used to like things where...
I just don't like play to win.
You know?
Like, I'm just being dipped by some guy that just has a
better gun than me.
That I don't have yet.
Maybe a little bit lower, alright.
Alright, let me know what's better, guys.
And it feels like it takes so long to unlock.
That's a thing.
Loyalists Cruise formed across both sides Fighting for turf,
power, community And the right to have an identity Then
there's Lancers They hold no allegiance Unbound, loyalist
Whoever has the best gig It was not super grimy I don't like
how it's super grimy about the it About it We now have a
chance to rebuild and set ourselves free It's in your hands
now What will you find all right here we go but i i decided
to try to do this game today just because it came out today
and like i said i i really i really don't want to fight
someone next week i don't want to play this game next week
because i feel like next week everybody would be too good at
this game i don't have a friend code guys can you use my
friend code yes I mean here's my friend code
if anyone wants to use it I don't fucking know what am I
gonna do with this
sure yeah all right you sure I don't wait what what did it
is it like refer what do I get out of it.
I don't even know what I get.
I was just like, just use it.
I don't know.
They just fucking use it.
Oh, was it a friend request?
What does it even do?
I just saw a code and it's like, here you go.
Do I get $5?
$5?
$1 runies?
Oh, guys.
Use my friend code so I can get in-game currency.
Oh, yeah, I also don't know how to adjust my sense for this,
too.
Alright, um, does it, did it actually, did it actually, I
don't even know.
What's the default?
Guys, is this already adjusted?
Five whole dollars?
Wait, guys, we broke, we found the loophole.
Oh, volume is low as fuck.
Alright, I pushed it back up.
Guys, does anyone know what the default sense is?
We're gaming the system.
I don't know if my sense carried over.
Just put that.
I don't know if it carried over.
Is that the default or should I lower it?
Oh, Team Deathmatch right off the bat.
Yeah, but it released this morning.
Yes, it released...
Oh, oh, it does carry over and lock the code.
No, it locked the gun.
I like the compressor the most.
But yeah, I don't have anything.
So, it's probably okay.
Alright, there we go.
Well, I don't really need the tutorial because I played it
already.
I played this... I played the demo because everybody was
playing it.
So, it's that...
Unroll
my gun was...
This is not gonna lie.
So yeah, you can wall ride and everything.
It's like basically it's just super fast paced.
And this is that...
I feel like... I don't even know if these are real people.
These are not real people.
There's no way.
This is Bobboss, right, for a tutorial?
Yeah, this is Bobboss.
This does not feel like my sense at all.
These are bots, right?
Yeah.
For those who don't know, it's Insta.
Wait, what?
Oh, they didn't nerf it?
Oh, they nerfed it.
They nerfed it.
For those who didn't know, the hammer was an Insta kill.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
The hammer used to be an instant kill, but not anymore.
Let's get out of the bot lobby real quick.
Let's get it out of here.
I mean, yeah, no, they needed to nerf it.
No, it was so broke.
Oh, shit.
No, but not a bot.
Oh, the bot's getting him.
Cheek.
No.
The fruit.
bot a bot scanning there is all right desert die to a bot
imagine dying to a bot where the fuck are there oh shit whoa
boom double kill whoa
Boop!
Oh shit!
Where's he?
Boop!
There we go.
Where's the mech guy?
I'll grab the mech.
I don't like the mech mechanic, by the way.
The bots can't aim.
It's like... it's... it's alright.
It's something.
So...
They can't kill me.
Oh.
That guy in particular.
There we go.
So I do have a shield.
But I can shoot out of my shield.
I can do it so that they can reload and then I'll shoot it.
Yeah, I can use the shield.
And then it'll just be like...
My cat's shooting.
Alright.
There we go.
It's dead.
Oh, I died.
I forgot any ejection time.
Yeah.
Audio, sound effects.
Down a little.
I don't remember if that was my...
I'm just gonna put three.
Fuck it.
It feels...
I think three would be better.
This felt high in general.
I couldn't tell if that was my...
Oh, never mind.
It's so...
though.
Does anyone know if it's a default?
I don't know.
Oh shit.
Try 3.49.
I'll do 4.
I just don't remember if this was default.
I really don't remember.
All right.
That's fine.
We'll let the bots take win oh
my god my aim is so bad right now if all fell spells oh wait
my team won a big wrench over mech thank you super chat
thank you thank you
yeah i were done with the bot lobbies it's just weird
playing bots the first oh my guys because i okay i now i
realize why i feel so fucky right now it's because i'm I'm
on a glass pad I forgot to put my actual mouse pad back on I
was like this feels so fast like why does this feel so fast
I'm not on my actual mouse pad I'm not on my fucking glass
pad all right there we go all right now now it should be
like real players
well does anyone know if if five is the default for game
does anyone know anyone in the game that's found out if
five's the default anyone in or they already adjusted it all
right this one is apparently an r9 dakota i feel like i was
doing more more work though with uh we'll try five is the
default okay all right let me do i have a converter out yet
let me try uh converter uh sense converter let's see yeah
intel secure the drive to transmit data to the cloud oh god
i hate that one that one sucks i hate that one actually what
game is called impulse nope impulse is still not in okay
never mind new drive I hate this game mode.
This is actually...
It's like basketball.
Oh my god!
It's like whoever has it longest.
It's...
Oh wait.
Oh, what's the word?
It's not basketball, but it's like...
Oh my god.
It's nice.
Alright, you just have to...
to move around, but to protect him.
All right.
There you go.
Is there melee?
No, there's no melee.
I don't remember if there is a melee.
No!
I walked into it!
It's like, no, it's not basketball with gun.
It's like, how do I explain it?
It's basically hold it for as long as you can.
That's the game mode.
You just gotta hold it.
And it's literally just movement.
It's like the guy who holds it just runs around.
No, this makes you move faster.
But like, I don't have the perks.
That's like really good for it.
Like, I have really shitty perks right now.
As in I have zero perks.
What the fuck?
Why do I have?
Who threw that to me?
I just hate this game mode.
I hate this game mode so much.
You can, like, get rid of some game modes, and this is the
one I would get rid of.
Oh my god, who has it?
There we go.
That would be a... Oh shit!
Oh shit!
Get me out of here!
Oh, of course I walk into the fucking mecha!
A fucking chorus!
You can kill the mecha!
it though.
You can kill him.
I just need it.
All right, it's fine.
Our guys got it.
Nice.
Please, someone else shoot him while I could hammer him.
Yeah, no, I hate this mech.
it so much it's so hard to kill him it's my gun doesn't work
in killing this cat like unless we all shoot him together as
a fucking team maybe but we're not doing that apparently oh
my god uh did a gamer subs order and user call we get flavor
eventually oh man shark thank you for the super chat thank
you i really appreciate it i was told that for for For it, I
basically have to, like, double my stilas if I want to get
the flavor.
But also, because, like, oh, shit, he's over.
Where is he?
But thank you so much for the support for helping me in
that.
Also, like, I think...
Oh, my God.
They have their mecha still alive?
But it's also my bad, because I haven't really talked about
the gamers of stuff in a while.
But there's also, like, a lot of stuff going on, too.
That guy's fucking camping the mech.
There's also like a lot of stuff going around so I feel it's
partially on me.
Partially on me for not like advertising too much.
Oh my god.
See this is why this is exactly why I hate having nothing.
I feel so fucking baby.
Compared to everybody.
Like!
Ah!
I feel like a fucking kid!
Everybody's so fast.
Alright.
I'll get me out of here.
It's also very easy to like...
Yeah, I just get team shot.
It's also very easy.
So like one of the...
I'm trying to remember...
Does anyone...
I don't remember how to swap weapons.
So there's a perk that's super good that makes like...
I could use...
Like would make me even faster and more HP.
But I don't have that perk.
So I'm just a fucking little baby.
Just a little little baby.
So I would have like regen or something.
I'm entering this mech.
There we go.
I'm just gonna, I'll protect him.
I'm gonna protect that guy.
There we go.
Alright, that's, that's five.
I don't take that risk.
I killed four.
Oh shit.
Guys, guys, I have it.
I was trying to cheese it.
I really wanted to cheese it.
Well, it's not durable only because I did not use a single
shield.
Okay.
This is the only way to cheese this.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
They...
Okay, they...
They fixed it.
So there was a cheese strat where you can run at the back
there.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize they patched it.
Because that's what they did to me.
That's why I was trying to do it.
Wow!
That's where everyone was!
Oh my god.
Yeah, basically the cheese was literally at the outside
area.
It was so frustrating.
I'm trying to remember how to change my weapon.
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
I won't change my weapon.
Fuck this weapon.
I don't remember what button it was.
It's been too long.
There we go.
Okay, I'm protecting.
Oh, nice.
We got it.
Was it escape?
I mean, I'm fine with that.
Let's cheese, but still.
Oh my god, what?
Oh my god, please protect me!
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
I dropped it.
I didn't want them to get near me anyway.
No, it does.
Oh dear, change the... I'll go back to the compressor.
Oh my god, we gotta grab him.
Somebody get him.
He's so fast.
Man, if only I had the...
If only I had the perk that he has.
I'm gonna try and protect Here you go Trying to protect him
Nice Oh my god There we go We'll try this one It's a little
slower paced
But it does more damage It's just I'm just gonna try for the
more damage route
Oh my god, he fucking He's wall riding guys There we go Oh,
they're right behind me, aren't they?
No It's approaching 10 seconds
No!
I get shot behind!
I hate this!
I hate this game mode!
I hate this game mode.
It's fucking sucks!
Fuck this game mode!
Okay, I should have my stuff upgraded now.
I should...
My stuff should be updated.
This is Thief.
I don't know how... I remember you can, like, change it.
I'm going to go back.
How do I change it?
You can't live in half the time.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
What was it called?
It was Intel.
No, this one sucks.
This one also, I mean, this one was crazy.
Destroy, capture the mech.
Return it to your base.
Control.
Okay, we'll...
We'll try slam dunk, but I hate data upload.
Data upload is just, it's just so cheesy.
It's really fucking cheesy because everyone just, oh my god,
the wall right, the movement for that is so cheesy.
Was that upload?
What is this?
That one is like, this one's capture the flag.
This one's also equally cheesy, but like, no, this one's
less cheesy than the other one.
was worse that other one was oh my god i hate i hated
playing that one i literally removed it instantly i forgot i
had that power i forgot i had the power to remove it
all right here we go
i'm ready
give me teammates why are you over there oh my god oh my god
oh my god no teammates are spawned by myself oh my god oh my
god I forgot oh my god I forgot people talk whoa here we go
there you go okay no people were so let's just say people
were like oh my god I still don't have the god fucking damn
it let's just say um when I played the demo, um, there might
have been gamer words.
Let's just say that.
It felt very, I definitely felt like I was playing games.
Oh, oh my god.
Like, if it was, I do not feel safe.
Let's just say I do not feel safe.
Okay.
oh no
yeah no I instantly did not feel safe when I when I was
playing this game during the demo it was really bad people
were like people were very let's just say people are
definitely gamers Jesus Christ the goddamn movement it makes
me like it's just like this is so hard to aim not gonna lie
I have zero attachments on my gun.
That's the worst part I Have no attachments on my gun still
so it's like so hard Because there's like oh my god.
Let's just there's so many good attachments and I wish I had
it
Oh, he's dead
Yeah, they were very enthusiastic About impulse See if I
waited a week these players These players would kill me
instantly.
Alright.
Nice.
No!
Oh, there's the mech.
Oh my god, we got four.
Oh!
Oops.
Oh, that was my bad.
I've never played on this map before.
You can steal other people's mech.
It's so broken.
It's so fucking broken.
there you go okay so what my perk is is that I get like
basically I get speed boost and restore health for every
like kill I get that's why it's such a good perk so I
basically live a little longer if I get a kill this is like
actual I feel like this game is like aim trainer so I feel
like super fast and like run away faster which is why it's
like it's i hate that it's so play to win in that case where
i'm just a little baby right now and i don't have like i
don't have the resources against peelers that i don't have
like gun attachments right now too this is still early
access though
oh my god i had too many people yeah i'm literally like uh
at a disadvantage right now.
It's okay.
There's no friendly fire.
So he died on his own.
I'm...
He didn't die?
No!
Okay, he died there, though.
Whoops.
I'll be over here now.
You know what?
I'll take your gun.
I don't know what this gun is, but I'll take it.
Oh my god.
What is this gun?
What is this gun that I stole?
I don't know.
I know it's this early access.
I mean, it's from the devs of Splitgate, so...
Was Splitgate on the PlayStation?
This feels very...
This feels like a console game.
I don't know.
It feels like a game you should play on console, you know?
It's pretty strong.
You hit your DMR.
Which gun is that?
oh my god i finally got a grip thank god
all right let me grab oh my god what i'm so okay i'm look
there's too many words on my screen is the resonance i tried
the resonance earlier i wasn't like a huge fan of resonance
but i'll try it again um i just like the wait his healing
zone I like the speed paint I just like to go fast yeah I'm
just like I don't know these guns yeah which one's the DMR
the hammer takes out the mech in four swings that thing is a
super chat thing you think yeah I know that the hammer is
like super fucking strong I just needed it's just every time
I looked at him he looked at me when I was playing a demo I
was just hammering the mechs but also the mechs were even
The hammer was even stronger than what it was before.
Okay, upload.
Okay, this one is like capture the flag and it's so cheesy.
Like literally, oh, isn't this?
Oh, never mind.
This is a bad map for capture the flag.
So it gets super chaotic if you have out of bounds.
Because like, you know, when they get close to you, you just
fucking run off.
You just run it out of bounds and then it resets in the
middle.
And that's what I was doing.
I literally got it and it ran out of bounds.
Like when it's on our side.
like soccer.
Yeah, I was on the offside.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
That is trying.
Wait, is that?
Was that...
Okay, that was not ours.
Are we gonna do objective, guys?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Enemy has the drive.
Okay, enemy has the drive.
Okay, we gotta protect the ball.
Where is he?
Alright, he has to come over.
Like, I'm waning.
I'm defense.
I'm defense!
Defense!
Drive recovered.
Oh, did you do long angle over here?
I can't like...
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
I can't oh shit oh shit oh shit all right we got it we got
it oh I'm
dead I'm dead nobody protected the goal I'm literally
playing soccer right now go go bro go I got your bro Bro!
Midfield is here!
Oh shit, midfield dead.
Midfield dead.
It's alright.
Defense.
Defense, defense, defense.
Oh yeah.
They rec- Oh yeah.
Oh, this is what they do.
They literally go to the middle.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Defense!
Oh
my god!
Boom!
Oh my god, it's three!
I hit him three times!
Where's the defense?
You drive, take him.
Someone else has to hit him!
God!
Hit him all!
Drive, recover.
There you go.
No, I got him though.
Defensing, defending.
There we go.
Okay, maybe the DMR is fucking strong.
Oh my god, it's okay, they threw it.
They didn't slap- if you slam dunk it, it's even faster.
Yes, he did.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
No, I was so close.
Oh, I shoved through it.
I shoved through it.
I shoved.
Yes, holy shit.
Okay, we did it Drive delivered all right Oh my god, I
actually fucking game there I game so hard there There you
go I passed it's just like soccer
Boom yeah, someone someone get over there over there.
Someone get over there.
I couldn't.
I couldn't shoot.
I wouldn't do so much.
Where's the ball?
No, he was one.
He is one.
There's no way.
There's no way he's one.
No!
They just didn't shoot him once.
They literally just had to shoot him once.
Mech spawn.
New drive detected.
Oh my god.
It can't be defense and offense, guys.
Oh, wait, that's what midfield is.
Maybe I can.
Technically, I can't.
I can't technically do both, but I really don't want to.
There you go.
Double kill.
Drive recovered.
No, he got the first shot on me.
I don't want to be midfield guys there's no one defending no
why is
my players in
offense guys why are we all on offense guys oh
my god I have to go back the drive I have to do defense
again oh
my god I'm defense I have to do defense I don't trust my
team.
Oh my god.
A mech!
Why are we not on the mech?
Exit!
Okay, see, this is why this is...
I swear I'm getting the mech.
I'm getting the fucking mech.
My team is actually...
They're selling so hard
I swear to God oh my god we still we dumped it we actually
dumped it oh my god we actually we actually scored it
What is it?
Oh, we actually got another point we actually got another
point New drive detected
I'd take this I'd take this
It's fine I'd literally He also He took another mech They
took another mech They took I'm fucking hammered I'm necked
out Drive taken Oh my god, I swear to shoot him once.
Shoot him once.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
That's how you do it, baby!
That's how you fucking do it, baby.
Where is it?
Okay
Oh my god, I got shot by too many people.
I got shot by too.
I really I I've not even shooting anymore I'm just trying to
do movement shit right now.
Oh Shit Oh, I can't I was gonna I couldn't do anything.
I was hoping my teammate.
Yes, my teammates
Next spawn Yeah, no!
I didn't even lie!
I just didn't even lie!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I didn't get the angle correct.
I literally stopped shooting because I felt like I was the
only one that I was doing the...
I felt like I was the only one doing it justice.
Honestly, I had to stop shooting.
I missed the 3.8.
nope i i was fracking out and now it's like okay i guess
i'll start shooting the goal i like nobody else wants to
shoot it
oh my god that's so fresh this is also why i hate that game
mode too because like nobody everyone just wants to frag out
everyone wants to shoot their gun i'm removing it nobody
does objectives guys nobody this is why i was like like it's
fun but nobody's playing i know everyone just wants to shoot
the gun i literally was like bouncing off walls and
everything too oh my god it's okay
it's all right guys it's okay
They never do People just want a frag
Alright which one is this
Team deathmatch Alright back to the deathmatch Do I have
another perk?
No Oh bad I got this though At least I got this Eliminate
the enemy
Alright Alright All right, team death match.
No, there's some exceptional try-hards in this game.
Like, oh, I feel it.
Nope.
I'm very low.
What?
Oh, my God.
Cocaine did it.
No running in my lobby.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's not fair.
That is not fair.
Alright, this is not a game for this gun, I think.
Everybody is way too close.
Everyone's way too close.
I can't aim down sight for this.
I can't ADS this.
Yeah, I can't ADS this.
I gotta change.
I'll go back to try the Coda again and then deadlock it.
Oh, alright.
Naked Coda.
Okay.
All right, Naked Koda.
Bye.
Either I don't find anybody, or they find me and I die.
What?
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
I'd fucking whiffed all those shots.
I don't even know if this is my sense.
I'm just, like, going by feel right now.
I'm not playing really well in this one.
Oh my god, this is so bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
I got this is so bullshit.
This is, ah!
I have to kill still.
I need this.
I need this kill.
There you go.
I needed that kill.
I needed that kill more than this guy needed life.
Alright.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, alright, that's fine.
Oh, if you're so lucky, it's nerfed.
He's so lucky.
He's so lucky that guy.
My team is not doing so well.
The fact that I'm top-ranking and, like, I had such a hard
time.
How did he get...
This is what I'm saying.
He has the perk that lets him have that little itty-bitty
heal.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting shot by 20 people.
I got shot by 80 people.
Jump to it.
Okay, it's fine, whatever.
Take that kill.
Oh, it's fine, whatever.
It's fine, whatever.
I'll stay up here.
It's alright.
Where even is anybody?
That's fine.
I got that kill, though.
That's all that matters.
I got that, both of those kills.
The aim's coming back.
Bro, what?
Where am I?
I'm stuck in a building.
But you see why I think this game wouldn't have a long
lifespan.
I mean, it's early access.
Maybe they'll add more stuff, but I hope it lives long
enough for them to do that.
Because I feel like it has potential, but it just feels like
a game that might not live too long.
Like, it feels, I'm just aim training, basically.
It's like an aim trainer.
Oh, this guy's good.
I got hit every fucking shot.
But he can't, he's not the best.
Okay, why is there 20 of your team?
Why are you hugging each other?
Okay, it's my bad for trying a 1v4, I guess.
My bad.
I don't know.
It just feels very simple.
It's just a very simple game.
Like it...
Can I wild ride from here?
I can.
Go, but think of a 10 gift and chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh, my God.
The first person I saw and he gets the first shot.
Well.
Yeah, but it is early access, so I'm just going to give it
to that.
That's why it's like it looks a little incomplete.
It does look a little incomplete.
I just think it's because it's early access.
I don't want to be the last kill of people.
No!
I'm just going to ride.
oh not me not me i saw the guy die so it's not me
that's my mission not last kill
not me
still want to be last kill no these were also also by the
way i didn't show it to you guys but this game it has game
chat game voice so at the end of the game you can hear the
enemy team talk shit and that's why i was like i do not
trust uh i do not trust them to not say anything because i
saw i heard some crazy things in game chat i i heard some
crazy games during game chat so i don't yeah i don't want i
didn't want to it has combined and lobby yeah no That's why
I turned off voice instantly.
I didn't want to get in trouble.
All right, guys.
I'm going to call here.
I know I just looked at it super briefly for you guys.
I get to play this game for a lot.
But it's like there's not really much to show.
Like, I feel like there wasn't much to show in general for
this.
It's like it's just a pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
way peep peep but it's like it's a fun game i feel like i
don't know if they have custom if they if they open custom
lobbies i i would love to do customs of these games in the
future um but uh yeah it's an early access so you know i'm
pretty sure more things are gonna change now but there's not
much to really show other than pew pew pew pew you know like
it's pew pew pew yeah anyway guys thanks for hanging out
with me today i hope you guys had a fun time uh with me as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and roll
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye